so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh top of the morning
top of the morning round what's going on
what is going on talk to people right
quick
lord metroid appropriately
in the realm what's going on let me know
my levels are sounding my boy david jay
almost is in the building with the full
government out there
she'll let bank what's going on hustle
in there i see you next what's up let me
know my levels is good have yeah mccain
what's going on brother what's going on
man buddy guys in the house i see you i
see you let me know how the levels is
make sure i'm crispy out here
loud enough for y'all
i appreciate you hustle okay don't
forget in a few minutes
you want to talk to the realm real quick
rrd what up
what's going on on this sunday morning
yo real quick thank you hardy what's
going on bk born gaming europe i see you
i see you yeah real quick um some lords
might be out today you know what i'm
saying we got um
my boy you know what i'm saying
[Music]
with no he's um battling
it's kind of like wisdom too big thing
going on so i'm pretty sure we might not
get out of today and it's all last
minute it might be a last-minute scratch
we'll see
we got some family stuff going on
[Music]
[Music]
yeah i see y'all see that metroid drag
talk we're gonna talk about that
battlefield all that good stuff bogus
craig what up the man with the plan
what's going on
salute salute salute salute so look
we're gonna get some people in here have
some fun
good day in the room so i'm gonna talk
to y'all in a minute
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when he was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and had this be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on the song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i'm addicted to flipping the sample
[Music]
i'm very spoiled for them to be your dog
thing very loyal but i ain't gonna hold
you i ain't here to boil you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell an uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i
[Music]
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
you ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed
for you i've always been a nerd never
been a loser making voltron with a gang
of cougars and i'm going places better
tell her uber cause it's pretty hard to
sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say i'm better
than money because you can bank on me
being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beating they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
[Music]
be your dog thing very loyal but i ain't
gonna hold you i ain't here to boy you
you ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed
for you i always been a nerd never been
a loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals on twitter but i'm
anti-social lower my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
i'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to started regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it um
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
um
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that
again here you hear you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started i am
well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh i guess i'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vote follow on twitter but i'm
anti-social lower my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to started regardless
back we was messaging people on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it um
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
[Music]
a proclamation
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if i can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice and invite your
girl to your squadron cause if you don't
give her that option you're gonna be
single player like siren you're gonna
get tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's the avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be neato i know it's my
destiny work to cognito who cares if you
fly if you steal a mosquito you swear
you ain't something but really
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news even if you
really was that jew king david still be
the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible wasn't it nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
all right hear ye hear ye and we are
live
welcome to the iron lords podcast comma
llc and the lords of gaming.net episode
number 228 it's another glorious sunday
we're back at the round table on the
lord's day i'm very excited about our
two special guests and we've got
battlefield 2042 beta
metroid dread impressions
jim ryan's latest interview and
king's laughing at chinese censorship to
discuss so we're going to get right into
it
so first i want to introduce a lord who
is not only a true friend and early
supporter of the realm but whose
outstanding work ethic and compassion
for his fellow content creator always
provides fresh new talented voices with
the use of his very own platform to
shine
introducing the creator and host of the
double barrel gaming youtube channel and
host of primetime gaming x pax factor
and the breakfast with boom podcast
new york city's finest
fellow switch gang member
and is my right hand on the hashtag just
one xbox movement
live from new rock city and making his
return into the realm of the lords
my man lord boomstick excel how we doing
sir oh i'm doing great man this is gonna
be a great show great topics great
community
and i um can officially and publicly say
that you guys hit in 10k
was one of the biggest highlights of
2021 for me personally because you've
been really grindstone in this for since
the beginning
and i remember
going back and saying hey guys listen my
channel is small but i think we got to
get more people out there and we did an
expose on the iron lords and man the
work that you i mean listen that was
nothing honestly that was nothing
because we were both so small back then
the work that you guys do each and every
week
that you that you're out here is just
tireless and it's well deserved and uh
it's an honor to be here today thank you
brother i mean boom you know we can't
say enough positive things about you
you've always supported day one and then
you know but one that's why part of my
intro for you was like i don't think
people realize how much you've helped
others i don't really think people
realize how much you've given so many
new voices a platform so um yeah man we
we got to support man you you you were
one of my votes for uh
the certain uh game awards uh thing just
sort of on the record you know what i'm
saying you know it's it's funny i i
appreciate that and look here's the
thing um
i've always been a community guy right
like my my whole career as a new york
city police officer was i went back to
my high school to my uh project that i
grew up in
and policed and you know
and and work with that community so of
course
i'm going to try and
bring that forward to you know to
podcasting and
i'm going to be honest with you let's go
yeah my i'm i'm closing under
them there 9 000
on we're close
we gotta get bored but here's the thing
regardless of size
i i think that if you do if you are
blessed enough to have a voice
in this community and it's hard folks
youtube is
hard yes the amount of talent that is
out there is far and wide so if you
could somehow navigate those waters
and find an audience
i feel it you i feel it almost behooves
you
to go around and help others because at
some point in your youtube career
whether you are of 9 000 or 9 million
subs you started out with just one talk
about that
and that is the same thing of people
like pong soul
and
mavs yes and boxing burger
and vijay yes and so many people that i
work with
that i think listen again my channel is
small and i don't know what i actually
did for anyone but to be able to say
that i help someone get into the
business oh for sure
is super important and i think more
people need to do that but i i've talked
enough nah you're good brother thank you
for paying it forward again hustle if
you get a chance if we can put booms on
youtube link in in the channel
and then we'll definitely we want to
support our brother man we're close
we're gonna 50 something away from 9k
come on we got more than 50 people here
let's get balloon pass that nine goals
read a couple super chat before i get
the next intro um hard i'll find member
for six months half a year with my guys
salute salute and again hard i find
tyson fight outside chat tonight let me
read it
let me read that oh oh oh oh oh oh
i was going for deontay because i root
for my people but his name is tyson fury
king okay okay yeah we gonna
broomstick xl and the lord and hashtag
the lord's day must love to both for the
opportunities you already know much love
to you dutch good dude neo mental final
super chat that's the bro right there
yeah brother
oh come on brother you you should have
tremendous love salute on the tank okay
100 super chat salute on the 10k sub
zion launch much success and love to the
realm king i will hit you up but grief
hits us all differently onward and
upward to the realm first of all salute
to that brother he was going through it
he lost someone very close to him the
fact that he's here and he's been a
supporter for as long as he has again we
can't even say any anymore to you
brother thank you so much and um big
cloud gaming ah salute five let's see
what you got my brother boom in the
building salute to the lords yo king
that wilder fight was a war 10 out of 10
performance from both men you we're
gonna get into that you already know and
thank you hustle for putting that in
there for boom make sure y'all hit that
subscribe button on boom let's get him
the 9k for this show man he always
pushes other people forward let's push
him forward
and of course we have a lord who is no
stranger to the realm of the iop and
whose namesake alone is truly an
accurate representation of what it takes
to succeed within the gaming content
creator space
introducing the creating host of the
hustle and motivate youtube and twitch
channels plus the co-host of the attic
show on ilp
the lord of physical media and retro
game receipts
and is the leader of the hustle hard
gaming movement
live from the dmv and making his return
into the realm of the lord
my man lord hustling motivate how we
doing sir
that's so hard but before i even get
into anything that i'm doing we got
another hundred dollar super chat from
everybody's big homie smitty smith yeah
um well cognito hold on wait wait make
sure i get it right well cognito
when laura cognito sends out a call to
arms to the realm make sure i get it
right y'all got it
we rise and respond lord sinister the
realm has your back shout out to smitty
blessings blessing we're gonna
definitely address that soon as soon as
we finish the intro smitty that was love
thank you for that really appreciate it
and again we won't get into the
specifics but um there is a link in the
description
for the uh the actual uh gofundme that
we're doing for law senator we'll get
into the details a little bit later but
sweetie thank you for that much much
love i can't even words can't express
but
lloyd hustle and motivate man yes good
to have you back in the round feel like
i haven't seen you what uh what is it
all a day ago on rgt yeah
the whole 24 hours yeah shout out to the
big clouds
on rgc yes um i see my i see one of my
up and coming content creators in the
chat the sly crow yes um you know like
like mr bloomstick all from the champion
uh people in our community as well um
the slide crow has a podcast called the
crow's nest okay please go check that
man out man click on his name and look
it up to the youtube go check that man
though he is really doing his thing out
here oh i'm doing great by the way i'm
doing phenomenal
because wow
they got one of my childhood memories
let's go
good with the legendary uh dj uh babito
garcia yes you know also known as the dj
cucumber slice
put some stuff it's a respectable let's
go that was the first game the word
commentary was implemented correctly
unlike wwf smackdown just bring it in
the way it was you could tell that that
was candy yeah this was an organic
feeling it kind of made me really want
to like go visit new york man go play in
the cage
bro iconic spots bro i was just at
record yesterday yeah yes sir yes sir um
i'm doing phenomenal man like again i'm
happy to be here i'm you know
i want to send prayers out to everybody
who's going through something at the
moment like this is yeah you know what
we're going through isn't easy you know
the one thing that i can always try to
tell people to do like in terms of it
put your mask on though yeah yeah
you're protecting yourself you're
protecting other people get vaccinated
whether you believe in that i'm
vaccinated i got my booster shot coming
up too get all that together dog we
supposed to you know want to
if you're not doing it for yourself do
it for the people around you at the very
least at the very least respectfully no
doubt no doubt you already know hustle's
good to have you up in here we got
another one coming through looks like i
can't pronounce it game gameonomics
looks like with i don't know what
currency that is
me either but yes dude bow to the lords
so game pass users got early access to
battlefield 2042 beta same as pre-order
people can we expect battle for
battlefield 20 42 to land on game pass
day one we will address we will address
you already know man but i thank you for
that so look man wait a couple of lords
down i want the realm to send some love
out to two of the laws the four horsemen
is kind of split today so first let's
send some love about the lord addict um
definitely not feeling well he actually
caught as hustle you know like he
actually all canceled um attic show
midstream like halfway through he's been
going through a vicious toothache wisdom
tooth type of situation i had it before
that's one of the worst pains ever send
some love to addict you know what i mean
he's going through it we're trying to
get that uh appointment moved up so we
can get the brother could get seen and
then send some love to solve there's a
chance he may make it but i don't want
to put him in a spot he's got some
family stuff going on so send some love
to solve you know what i'm saying send
some love to attic but we still got
the incredible hulk of this aka the
access came out
the prophet of xbox swami
king of the style waiting king of
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience it is the leader
of the fraud alert movement
be
loving
lord k how are we doing sir
oh you guys know exactly how i'm doing
fighting last night um i'm not gonna lie
man 79
boys yeah it hit different when when you
see the 79 dollars pop up
and you want to say yes or no
[Laughter]
i ain't gonna lie if i missed it i would
have killed myself
um but um
yo so the undercard looked like the
worst undercard ever right it looked
like literally the worst on the card but
whoever was the matchmaker for this
undercard did a magnificent job
all the way through and led off right
before the main event
with a very strategic uh fight with
sanchez and edon that that fight was so
good that
in a lot of dudes was kind of pissed off
because other fights ended in knockouts
um
a good matchmaker understands that you
pair up people of equal skill right
before the main event no doubt the
rounds in
all right let's get into the main
schedule
for deontay wilder over the um alleged
uh
you had you had some accusations out
there these streets kid
no but i mean
he said to himself you know what i'm
saying
substance abuser
anyway um
i'm i'm going to tell you this yes
when you see
and i told you the winner was going to
want to have to die in that ring
both men
was willing to die in that ring
yesterday yes sir well only one man got
the kill
you understand what i'm saying so
i mean
i saw because you know my girl started
screaming
when she's like baby he in trouble he in
trouble he in trouble
when he caught fury with that punch
i said on ry himself
you thought i thought it was odd i was
like oh he got
himself you can't take away what god
giveth and god gives that man the power
to put people to sleep
sleepy john that is true he caught him
boy said oh where's my legs
he gave his soul in that round yes
and he was dejected yeah it took at
least for him three rounds to get his
soul back
[Laughter]
but i'm not gonna lie tyson furry is
probably the
biggest most skillful sloppy dude
the whole fight he fighting one cheat
show out
you can't be beat by a dude with one
cheat show out like he's got one cheat
show hanging out the back and if y'all
go watch this
[Laughter]
i don't care how you do it
you you put down the dude that looked
like adrian adonis true you put him down
the dude with the skinny legs yes let me
tell you something for all you
up-and-coming fighters
road work means a lot yes i've saw
deontay wilder and i said this man did
not jog one day bro what's up with the
extra weight like we do in the body what
we're doing i understand that he felt
that he needed because fury was leaning
on him the whole fight yeah yes big man
tactically yeah if he didn't put on that
extra weight to come in there at uh i
think was 238 his highest weight ever
if he didn't have that extra weight fury
was leaning on his neck deonte did a lot
of things that he always does wrong i
don't care who your trainer is i don't
care what's going on you're going to go
back to your old habits
tyson fury is the gypsy king yes tyson
fury earned everything it was a point in
a fight when deontay hit him flush in
the face yeah that was like the knife
with you yeah i remember that and he he
i saw him bite down on his mouthpiece
and i said that's the championship yeah
you did
yeah i gotta jump real quick cause um it
was a wild fight it was one of
situations like what you just said and
i'm like you know what i can't miss this
this is gonna this feel like the event
of the year i gotta put that bread down
so i go watch it and it's funny like you
said like to me was just it's it's
natural skill and talent versus you know
what i'm saying natural talent raw
talent and you don't say it versus that
the power stuff and the thing about it
was that like
the fact that deontay wilder could get
away like
i'm tweeting i'm like why this man
running around with one hp
and he's still right like he got no
energy i'm like yo how is he even
standing so credit to him for even
still a minute long you have to get that
along into the fight right and then
the other thing i notice about him
though
he because he looks like he's dead but
if he catches you
it's over he's alive he gets like all
his energy coming back
every time he caught fury it was like
yo you just looked at dead on your feet
the whole back but as soon as you get
one you could tell and it's like if he
somebody teach that boy uppercut no okay
let me tell you something those are the
two best heavy weights that you saw in
the world
if if if anthony joshua gets in the ring
with anyone at all
good night irene
usic is too small for either one of them
um so
what you have you you have a situation
where i don't think deontay fights again
yeah
i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you something
king i'm gonna tell you something mm-hmm
poor sportsmanship yeah that was bad
well we'll stain
that man went over you shared blood with
that man you you and that man have
fought three fights you have made money
you have fed your families you have put
food on the table you have gave
countless um moments of entertainment
and you could not walk over to that man
and say thank you for the opportunity
for giving me the chance to try to win
back my title i mean whatever was said
before the fight yeah that's that's here
and there that's the but you're as a
fighter understand what it takes to get
up that road and that man stood up to
your best because i don't want to hear
anything excuses there's no cheating
he can't blame the
dude for throwing a towel he wanted to
go out in the shield right he went on
your shield
his shield
he was on the floor with his shield
down there but
this man
walked out the ring
this is where anthony joshua will always
have my respect oh for sure for sure he
lost that fight with alexander
and stood there
as a champion yeah gave his respect for
sure said i'll come back a fight another
day today wasn't my night whatever the
hell whatever you gotta say yeah but you
don't do that champ and it's gonna stain
you because you're going to look like a
sore loser of paul sports so i'm here
today taking all your heat because i was
front lining for you dude i put my video
up i gave my prediction 10 round and i
thought the horse hit and i noticed the
gloves was not horse here it was so
pissed off but again guys um great fight
everybody that did watch the fight and
everybody that did get at me oh y'all
was looking for my knees yes yeah yeah
yeah sure your knees we were looking no
nobody took a bet no [ __ ] oh nobody
better yeah that's right true true
y'all was yelling out bet and dude was
like but um
we we gotta put it on live but uh
game-wise sir what have you been playing
sir oh wait yo so okay so this is this
game called the facade yes right um and
it's it dropping game pass it was a
stone plot so i'm like what's this
facade joint
buddy
it is the most horrifying
yo first of all
shout out to the game that shot starts
off with a man
killing his wife
and they kill kids oh what's going on in
here he killed kids okay and he shot
himself what is going on but then they
didn't then then you wake up someplace
it is yo
what was that game um that resident evil
that that that was that never uh
launched that was on the playstation pc
yeah okay mm-hmm
imagine pt right
it's on your own game pass okay
buddy
buddy are you talking about vistridge
yes yeah that game is horrifying okay so
i i was playing that i was playing um
mighty goose you know all right you're
doing your goose
doing a little bit of trials this
weekend but doing so much stuff cleaning
and doing all this stuff so really don't
have no doubt let me let me get it i'm
trying to give a shout out to my sons
yes i took my sons out yesterday and
it's it's it's it's such of a pride for
a father to see
um both lives like i have a 10 year old
and a 21 year old
and i'm like
look at me there's a whole bunch of me
in there
looking to go see venom too
um
movie was um yeah uh it wasn't as good
as the first one to me um but then i
took them to the chinese buffet oh
salute
yeah of course game pass took him to
gamepad
premium
they had a good time there but yeah
that's what i was doing yesterday no
doubt shout out to gaming for take super
chat follow us on chat some of my
favorite entertainers on one podcast
love to support every last one of you
show plus boom helps out everyone
including me thanks oh thanks brother
appreciate it
oh and we got it he's like we got
hard i'll find a good 10 super chat i
feel like they should have blurred out
tyson's boobs i know it was pbv but come
on king any interest in the esports
boxing game my name is har two fine
thank you for correcting me hard because
now you see the two look like a two l
thank you hard too far my bad brother so
you interested at esports boxing yes of
course any anything boxing that comes
across um plus we haven't had a game a
good boxing game since year tonight so
i'm waiting for that no doubt no doubt
and of course we got the gaming ninja
himself the shinobi lord cognito
spreading that realness in the roman iop
not telling what you want to hear but
what you need to hear shout out to my
brother mr maddie plays the fighting
duke is up should be 3.99 in a another
hour or two to check that out if you
want to catch that you know what i'm
saying if you also a part of their
patreon at last media you can also check
out the ultimate we did on the halo
infinite big team battle breakdown
dissection you know what i'm saying get
that you know that real good halo talk
you know what i'm saying so check that
out when you get a chance um last word
we had that actually on friday sure i
got to shoot out the legend man tom
warren from the verge pulled up man
fantastic discussion shout out to bontes
shout out to guy travis please check
that out that is up right now on the iop
youtube channel and um yeah for me it's
just been um it's been phoenix point
i've been really rocking that hard body
that's all the guy the original creative
xcom oh yeah he's got his own game his
own vision it's and that's only on pc
right no it's in-game past console sir
now it's in game pass
it was at one point but this week it
kind of came out there obviously
battlefield we'll talk about metroid
dread we'll talk about uh destiny um
play a little bit of trials and stuff
like that shout out to cedric h who
upgraded his membership salute but the
christmas lessons i'm saying whatever
whatever but uh real quick man just
wanna play something for the realm you
know real quick and uh we'll be right
back
hey guys little cognito here with uh
some unfortunate news i definitely uh
want to speak to you everyone in the
realm and um as you know ilp we're
pretty big and
we've got a lot of clan members and
associates and friends and this one goes
out to one particular friend in
particular from uh growing up from back
in the day since our channel five days
lord sinister
many of you may be familiar with him
he's always playing destiny with us in
the ilp clan
if you played uh or you've been in xbox
live party chats with with me and
anybody from the the ilp fam you know
the sinister name he's always in the
chats always having fun and uh probably
helped you in a raid or two
but uh unfortunately we're sad to
announce that you know his mother
um recently passed away this morning and
uh we definitely want to send our loves
and thoughts and condolences to his
family to him as you know his beautiful
wife and son and children and then
obviously his bomb which we lost he lost
suddenly and this year has been a rough
year for him it's particularly because
uh in april he lost his dad to covert
complications and his grandmother as
well so um
if anything the realm could do
you know when a fallen lord has fallen
down and going through a tough time you
know we want to reach out and we want to
help as best as we can so i'm putting
this out there call of arm to the realms
just help our brother lord sinister aka
ergarter ortiz
good friend i've known this kid you know
since uh back in the south bronx just
playing games good guy and going through
some tough times so whatever we can do
to help would be greatly appreciated and
to really send off his family the right
way so it's lord cognito here again any
help is appreciated and thank you for
your time
yeah guys thank you so much for
listening to that um the link for my
brother sinister
uh is in the description i will put it
the uh gofundme link realm if you guys
anybody could help that would be greatly
appreciated i'm just throwing that in
there right now you know no one should
go through what uh sinister is going
through right now brother i see you in
the chat uh i'm happy that you're here i
see you right there everybody in
community loves you you've always
helping everybody so it's only right
that the realm come together and help
you you know and he was a good friend
king i mean this is the channel five
days in the cribs
we made it to attacking
halo you know what i'm saying that boy's
a beast man so we love you bro and don't
think you're alone in this we're not
gonna let you rock out like that but uh
salute to my bro sending stuff but thank
you realm for your kindness i want to
read uh super chat or two obviously we
got super uh
we got you brother kool-aid 117.
xbox state halo infinite is releasing
early on the anniversary date of 11 15.
with battlefield delayed and cod looking
weak as hell sometimes you just got to
lay your meat on the table oh my god
kool-aid has been around us a little bit
too kool-aid has been around
hey yo you used to use it
damn it
anyway let's get before we get to the
top let's get into this poll last week's
phone results are in and the people have
spoken to the question with all the
recent announcements of xbox at tgs were
you satisfied with microsoft presence at
the event the winner at 45 percent of
the vote was yes they are making steady
long-term moves with japanese game pass
games id and xbox xcloud and
localization group coming in at second
place not that far 30 percent of the
vote was no they are not doing enough in
the region they need to be more
aggressive and not ex be excluded with
bigger games from japan and then last
place with 24 percent of the vote was i
don't care y'all go and bend the knee
when kojima pulls up in the xbox realm
group salute to all the lords that
participated lord king you are
victorious the realm agrees with your
thought process that xbox is doing it
the right way what say you sir
i say that you know you have to give um
like like like i'm telling paul you have
to give these rookies a chance let them
grow you know you know my paul my man
paul me and paul is jets fans yeah right
now you're playing in london right now
yeah yeah yes sir yes shout out to colin
coleman
early in the morning stuff
but
you we have to get through the growing
pains and you know everybody wants them
to oh you know pair up with konami and
have these giant games from square
we have to get what we can
and also grow the ground up you know so
again you have to cultivate the youth
and i see them doing that and and then
they understand okay well you know
microsoft isn't that bad
so when they do have a breakout game who
do they go to that dude that was
reaching back you see how boom
reached back for us yes to pull us up
into the situation it's it's about each
one teach one and i'm loving the moves
that's a great
what microsoft is doing they're reaching
down to pull up um younger developers
while also reaching up to talk to the
ones that really don't look at them that
much but you know they got really good
games inside game pass i love with the
direction they're doing especially in
that region and all those games this has
been the biggest month for rpgs in one
shot yeah
japanese rpgs oh yeah they're yeah for
sure we're seeing games that we didn't
we didn't see before would never be on
it on the planet nexus oh yeah
absolutely absolutely so you don't want
to hold up sorry i'm sorry i'm going to
echo king's point yeah go over um
cognito the last time you were on the
attic show remember how i said um xbox
kind of needs to cultivate talent yeah
let's see how they're getting with the
indies and everything like this is
actually how you do it um i didn't know
that all of that was going on behind the
scenes so this is interesting to know
man like
xbox is coming and we see how
playstation are treating the indies
shout out to um i know his name isn't
ariel knight but oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
i know you thought yeah yeah
he went off on twitter a little bit
about being treated a certain way by a
certain brand and he was referring to
playstation so when we see things like
this well first of all you know in the
indies they you know they drive the
creativity in the space anyways of
course so when we see things like this
this is nothing but a good thing man i'm
i'm i'm excited for xbox right now i'm
actually excited to see what they
produce no absolutely absolutely salute
right now and if i can just add to that
yes
um if listen i i obviously i'm closing
on 8 000 followers on twitter which is
bonkers right but i have to say that in
the last couple of months and i think
everyone might be able to agree with me
here have you seen the japanese posts of
people getting their series s yes
it has been i had about 15 of them
yesterday and of course you know welcome
to the family congratulations and
everyone and these are all japanese
players
a little bit out here in japan
there is something to be said about the
series s it does fit their lifestyle it
does fit their kind of play style
remember you know we're og's everyone on
here we remember reading the ig uh the
the egms back today
when they would show the lines around
the the store twice over for days
because that's they were a console uh
community back then now they're into
digital gaming they're playing on their
phones they're playing on their tablets
they're playing in in the pc um you know
the laptops and what just so happens to
have what does microsoft have while they
have something called uh cloud gaming
and xbox game pass
and when and when you now when you when
you go out there and you say hey listen
we have partnered with 200 indie
developers to bring you titles that
you've never seen before on xbox well
you're on to something oh absolutely
definitely definitely honestly man i
agree to boom in a sense that um at the
end of the day i like the the
cultivation of talent with id and xbox i
feel like you start on that independent
scene as well you might get the next
future you know what i mean big
development everybody had to start
somewhere so i i love that aspect of it
shout out to jacob j member for three
months good morning lords and boom much
love to y'all who's ready for some back
for blood no doubt no doubt me sir dude
let's get into these topics man topic
number one
you know what time it is okay
it's beta boy time
better boy stand up it's a big one out
right now cake did you partake did you
partake
he wasn't one of us
he wasn't out here with that battlefield
2042 wasn't gonna happen
listen man kkk better boy with us
i like my food cooks
he ain't getting this one two on but
it's cool it's cool it's better boys
season you already know what it is yo
slow-mo said did i hear about this one
listen man y'all know what it is first
one up to docket man let's get it that
battlefield 2042 so look like it's open
right now from the sixth to the ninth
checking it out believe uh one map
forgot the name of the map off top but
uh i just want to get a sense of who has
played let's start with a boom boom he
had a chance to jump in the battlefield
beta sir
you know what i i actually haven't and i
will say this um i you know obviously my
my brothers at
uh prime time gaming we talk pretty much
like we do every day
um and they're all battlefield guys i'm
an old-school battlefield guy from way
back in the o.g xbox i love battlefield
i have hundreds and hundreds of hours
they walked away very unimpressed
so much so that um watching some of the
video i actually cancelled my pre-order
oh
yeah i hadn't i had the big boy version
i was like you know something there's no
reason to spend this money
on a game that i feel is gonna launch
half-baked oh and uh when
when the don is coming home i'm talking
about master chief
does any other multiplayer game matter
the answer is no it doesn't battlefield
can take a knee call of duty is gonna
take a knee fortnite's going to take a
knee apex legend is going to take
call of duty warzone
are all going to bow down to the master
chief when he releases december 8th and
after that beta that i played with
listen
there's no what what other multiplayer
games are we talking about
so are we are you implying that it
doesn't matter what these other
multiplayer games do boom that that the
king is back and you have you have you
have already played greatness in your
mind
it's funny because one of the topics i
wrote for primetime gaming for monday
was in fact this and here's the here's
the problem with battlefield its biggest
competitor is itself because it's paid
you have to buy in into battlefield to
play it
okay now again warzone is called dude's
gonna be war zone but they also still
have a new call of duty which by the way
looks like xbox 360 graphics
here here's my thing
have have the stars and planets aligned
for 343 to present the 23 maps at launch
now when you talk about a delay this
might be one of the greatest delays in
the history of gaming
when because remember we were all bent
out of shape when it was announced right
and now when you look at battlefield
when you look at call of duty and you
look at what is presented in the betas
the king dog right now is master chief
okay hold on all right boom you talking
now i got i got to push back a little
cause you you you out here your chest
out you're talking straw i feel it
a lot of the points you're making are
very valid i i believe
in your defense paul taxi just put out
an article this morning saying
after playing all three he's agreeing
with you he's like the clear consensus
is is halo halo infinite you know so as
far as that is considered but i want to
throw a wrinkle into this boom and i
want to put your vibe before we get to
hustle is
what if not at the reception is what the
reception is
what if battlefield says yo you know
what
phil um about that game pass bag he was
offering
now if the if it jumps in the game and
we know halo infinite's free to play but
if battlefield and here's the funny
thing if y'all notice when you go on
that xbox dashboard
that beta got that game pass logo i've
never seen that for a beta say that gay
past ultimate members you rock a kid got
it
can you get your bars off real quick i
just told you something
and when when it happened because i said
it a long time ago
he sure did because i was just going to
say that if i recall the conversation
he said that it was going to come into
xbox game passes
and the thing is
let me go get my that fomo be killing
you dude your wallet be stinking mad at
me
here comes me this is you know what is
equivalent it's equivalent of you did it
overnight
in front of the store waiting to get
your game
i'll hop out my car
and then just walk right
inside we
disrespectful to the gamestop dudes that
spent the night
you was out there all night you had your
funny and your popcorn you were
shivering you got stories to tell i just
hopped right out the car walked inside
got mine and just left and you
you because the fomo gotcha and when it
drops in game pass i'm gonna have so
much fun with that game
and i'm going to tell you
i love it back but i told them though
you did now you did i want to give it
back i mean i i i will i will answer
your question and i think you're
definitely on to something but here here
here's the thing the question really
shouldn't be let's go
if it's going to be there right
can ea
and dice afford for it not
to be an xbox game pass see that is the
question because here's the thing okay
i think if you're if you're gonna put
battlefield versus call of duty that
match is over this is like the fight
last night
come on boom that was competitive
all right well you know what we'll we'll
say that call of duty will show up when
you start putting laser sights into a
game in the 1950s
what you're doing is saying that this is
some sort of an elsewhere this ain't a
dc game this is supposed to be
call of duty and how are we getting
modern equipment for a 1950s games you
know what that's called that's called
like well we're just going to throw
everything at the wall whatever stick
sticks
okay so battlefield versus call of duty
in the paid aspect i i think this is
just my opinion
battlefield hits him in the mouth and
takes their lunch money okay so right
now you got battlefield defeated
battlefield has beaten call of duty
hands down because
taking a a couple of steps back and i
think because of all the development
hell that we heard
going on and activision's got other
problems right they got other big
problems and has it has seeped into
development right okay so there's that
yes
so then you talk about master chief
let's go right obviously
for a lot of people
halo is multiplayer right it is it is
multiplayer first see for me it's single
player i'm i'm an old object yeah right
so i am looking forward more
to single player because we're going to
get a different we're going to get a
different chief story yes than we've
ever had
multiplayer we expected it to return in
a big way and they have delivered 343
figured out a way
to make it a bungee style game with
their stamp all over it and hats off oh
every one of three four three industries
because those betas
were legit yes
okay
um
so now you bring into the question for
the first time in the history of gaming
in the history of the franchise
it's going free to play and it's going
up against fortnite and apex legend and
call of duty war zone
and and it's and it's and it's halo and
big team battle is back
you know i mean
it's giving me goosebumps just
right so then you have to ask yourself
battlefield everyone has been waiting
for a modern battlefield to return it
has returned
it it has gotten lukewarm feeling you
know some people love it some people
like ah you know some people don't like
it
but when you say
do you go up against the o.g king who is
now arriving
and go paid versus free i i don't know
if they could win that battle not fair
enough let's get let's get hustling man
hustle man we
talked about it on rgt shout out to a
big cloud up in there shout out to blaze
um but you know what that has been out a
little bit more more chance to kind of
digest your impressions of it and then
also the question right like it's it's a
war going on outside no man it's safe
from there's a multiplayer war going on
survival of the fittest bomb deep style
so i wanna i wanna get you a vibe with
both of that like you know your
impressions and
ranking like can it survive this whole
multiplayer war coming up this fall
it don't matter if you three feet at a1
yes yes yes it definitely can survive
and i'll tell you why although i
disagree uh i just i know
i disagree with you boom um okay
cod
whether the gaming community as a whole
is sarah on it that joint still won't
as far as the game play in battlefield
although i haven't played this uh beta
for battlefield i played the last
battlefield what i love about
battlefield in particular is the fact
that it rewards you for being a good
teammate i said this on rgbt yes
hey look i ain't cool on that gun play
however i will pick you up when you are
dying oh you the guy what i'm down
hold on
i tossed them
i have to shout out the game for this yo
king i know you're not a beta boy i know
you're not but
this game has the funniest medic i'm
down how how about it
this game it's literally like a core
mechanic to scream on the yellow for
help so someone can get you i just had
to give them a shout out on that because
they got it's the funniest thing it
could
continue
some people
don't aren't shooters yeah but they can
help them both for show fishing i'm sure
continue
indeed indeed um now i do want to take
this to halo infinite okay let's go for
all intents and purposes and i said this
the other day
it should be a slam dunk this should be
the tracy mcgrady off the glass that is
served right you want to put it out
there this is
it's right there it's right
all you gotta do is grab it it's right
there
off the lego orlando magic tracy
yes
yo listen halo got to perform
on the multiplayer front which i'm
confident in because i played the big
team battle beta and i played before
these little slayers it's official i'm
rocking with it yeah iraq's with a heavy
super heavy ass however
we still have a little bit of a doubt
there because of that that single player
if the story don't hit like halo reach
of course then what are we really saying
also boom i want to take
i want to take the time to enlighten
everyone on the panel and everyone in
the chat
where the most cheaters found don't
worry i'll answer that for you this
isn't free to play games because the
level of entry is so low that you know
it's free
the new halo runs on the xbox one x
which is how i played it it'll still run
and still runs fine so you still got to
worry about cheetahs running rampant man
so that's another thing that you gotta
worry about at least with battlefield
yeah
so these are the other factors that you
have to worry about okay yes yes king
yes yes okay excuse me
i didn't think he was gonna do that
he had to clear his throat
for the disrespect yeah yo he definitely
he's a boy
let's go okay so um one first i agree
with you with the cod um definitely
going to eat these dudes lunch you know
um you got to beat the champ to be the
champ
battlefield been fighting that fight
they ain't winning okay um and then when
you have the war zone and you have the
halo multiplayer that's free to play
dude um sorry that's a fight that you
can't win and um that's why i knew it
was going to game pass okay so when it
gets into game pass then that the
barrier of entry for certain individuals
will be lessened and the game can
actually grow right very vip issue
there's certain individuals that he's
very very xbox bougie with that
if you are not in the club you cannot
come in
you do not have your green wristband
please step to the side
you can't do it like that
you know when you're walking down the
line and to do this agreement excuse you
and the dude without the green ones
that's that that's that that's that
that's the game pass experience it's a
green wristband situation without is
holding it like this
step to the side
you shall not partake are you paying for
that you shall not pass okay so
um
the greatest thing that microsoft did
was separate the two and make one entity
into a multi-player free-to-play yes
that's inside game pass
it's not beholden to the campaign
the campaign could be garbage that's a
good point it could be hot dude
no no no no no let me tell you why it
came
that's the paid-for version that's the
paid for
right so you paid to partake right some
dudes don't have to and if they got game
pass
green arm man
[Laughter]
so
again
free to play yes more people playing
you will have more people playing that
wouldn't even even know halo got a
campaign
god actually wouldn't even know that
they like who this master chief dude
jumping on the roof this is lit he got
another game let me go buy that this is
the genius behind that
okay so i'm having fun doing this
wait a second they have a whole
storyline
this is for new people
this game is not beholden on the
campaign to be good
actually they separated them
so it can live on its own it's a whole
different entity
so that's where i feel that your logic
that the campaign has to hit
the campaign could be i got you once
okay also yeah i know you would cover
what's your responsibility
can you do the homie king but if the
campaign wasn't quote unquote if it
doesn't have to be good but i didn't get
jason stanton up out of retirement
no no
i finished my point
he had this he had his feet kicked up he
had this bahama
it don't matter what type of bread they
them of course they're going to get you
got to be compensated for your work now
that definitely has to happen yes sir he
said
i'll be there in a minute let me let me
get myself together so we stretched
he said yeah bonnie don't worry miss
ross
so that story has to be on point and if
it wasn't on point that we the drop the
joint last year because the multiplayer
let me for all intensive purposes that
multiplayer if it's anything like five
we know it was going to hit anyway right
first and foremost right we knew that
that was going to win again it's going
be feasible
you ready
go yes sir ready yeah jason got that
call well jason got the call
craig
[Laughter]
craig was
craig was responsible for the call i'm
gonna tell you right now no craig no
call to buddy dude no call
we get we get the campaign however we
get it no call
so we have to yo they have to show
we put the best on that we got rid of
that craig stuff you ain't gonna have
that problem we do we we did have a
visualization issue early on with this
and we will not be having that issue
cause jason is here it's no problem
we're gonna go forward we're gonna get
the multiplayer we're gonna get the
campaign everything gonna be nice
listen no cray
no j let me let me ask this because
hustle's making an interesting point
that i didn't think about though and i
want to bring it to boom which is
we all agree
that the advantage halo infinite two
advantage one the consensus right now
seems to be the multiplayer for halo
infinite seems to be the best out of the
bunch right yeah so the second thing is
though like as far as
if
hypothetically like what hustle is
saying the campaign is not good let's
just say it is
not
good
does that affect
the war so to speak you know or is it
like what king's saying well where's
like it's since it's separate it really
doesn't affect the multi-player
components but what do you think about
that but i'm curious about your thoughts
there it's it's an interesting thought
and both men are right and here's why um
i didn't play
nearly as much of of halo 5's war zone
because i couldn't stand stomach the
story like it took me two years after
the game released to beat it and i beat
it just to say i beat it like i didn't
want to go into the next halo saying i
didn't beat halo 5 because i have
destroyed every other halo before that
multiple times over this one i played
through once and i was it was a very
very forgettable story okay
so for me as a die-hard halo fan who has
tons and tons of halo you know
collectibles and you know really looking
forward to this game
it would be it would i i honestly would
be a little bit dejected um if uh if the
story
doesn't match the same right
level of excitement and polish and and
uh charm
as the multiplayer has already you know
done for me you know just in the beta
right but at the same time there is a
subset of of younger gamers that are
probably in their 20s yes who don't play
single-player games with us remember
we're all the ones yeah
who plays on our couch with a controller
and a tv
there is a there's a subset of the of
the community the fortnight the you know
free-to-play gamers that are much
younger that grew up playing on their
phones and their tablets and they're
playing these free-to-free-to-play games
any way they can and a single-player
story would not appeal to them that's a
good point because they they just want
to you know go and play with their
friends and the multiplayer right so it
is a double-edged sword i will say this
bringing joseph back
said a lot of things
um it said honestly they were not
confident with current leadership um
they they were not confident with the
current story uh that was presented um
and uh we know that um he came in
he made some monster changes for the
single player and i believe we're going
to get an incredible experience i
honestly believe we're going to get an
incredible experience
but that that's my take on it i think i
think it is i think it is
it i don't think you can honestly say
from one side or the other
someone is more right than others it
depends on the community you're trying
to appeal to now you make a valid point
and they're trying to get both like
these this is the first time
literally
they're trying to cater to both
equally
in in a in a fashion i i tried to
explain to people
everybody keeps looking at this halo
like the last halo like five
or four it is not the separation from
church and state
actually tells you right then and there
they're playing a different church
[Laughter]
the single player state is over there
i mean
you and make a good point i'll jump if
you if you finish um yeah you both make
good points not the hustle's also making
a fantastic point as far as a single
play and it's important i it's it's
interesting because um
like you said they're attacking for too
fast but i do want to focus my thoughts
initially back on on battlefield and you
know for me i am a battlefield guy you
know when i saw the the trailer it
looked absolutely amazing
phenomenal this game is a beautiful
looking game on the series x it is
absolutely stunning shout out to mr
maddie plays for my calls from defining
duke he's playing it on pc like on the
39es like this thing looks glorious so
i'll start with the good first the good
it it looks amazing
this orbital map is huge 128 players all
type of madness going on i'm a conquest
boat dude and i love i've always been
confident yeah i've always been conquest
you know capture the points and what i
like now is besides like abc
they got these little mini ones they got
a little conquest so yo go go capture
that building over there that counts as
something so you don't have to just run
to like three areas it counts as well
now the thing that i played about three
two matches i'm like yo where's the
you know the gimmick
the revolutionary thing i was like
to the third man shot the attic the
attic was playing
and yo when that tornado twist to come
bro you gotta get out of town bro it's
it is so crazy people are funny because
they playing the game they want to see
it so they running towards it like i'm
seeing 128 players running towards the
twister i'm like what are they doing but
i go for it i kind of did it because i
want to see what happened because you
bro you cars in the street swirling
anything caught in the mix it's crazy
now the funniest thing is you get caught
you know in battlefield when you jump
off a high thing your parachute could
come out
if you run into the twister you get
sucked up all the way to the top so your
parachute you you it's like a roller
coaster
why am i having a shootout with another
dude
in the twister in the past and we're
sitting there like yes
i go afraid it was fun it was fun
it's fun i'm not going for it's fun the
attachments is it 70 dollars worth of
fun i don't know if they said that's fun
it is game pass fun because you're a
multiplayer only but i'm gonna finish
i was just about to say that yeah that
was me going after hustle's uh situation
i already know what you were trying to
do all right you're being a messy mess
but um the attack the attachments on the
fly
is is a game changer like you i think
it's the whole lb you can put your scope
on like i love that it's just really
cool and the vehicles are fun because it
evolved yeah interface and then the last
thing i'll say on the good side is the
customization like number four is like
all right medic assault there's that
now you could be like no i want to carry
a med cat even though i'm a sniper or
whatever whatever i want it's limited
fool somebody
get wait wait you could put on phony
clothes without foldy clothes but you
could pick a class that has a preset
but you could kind of like pick a tree
build your own yeah you kind of come
with your little customization so that
aspect is fire now we gotta get to the
bat
all right
the guns this is just a cognito thing
the guns to me the sounds the sounds
ain't really
i don't know maybe it's just i don't
know i just didn't like that punch for
me
i i'm a fan of battlefield 4's the
spotting like i call it the stitch but
yo over there
you know what i said so the snitch
button ain't as prominent as i would
like
i'm telling uh officer friendly i'm
telling
you
uh that's my role on the team i'm like
yo he's over there in the jeepness
fordham go get them over there i'll go
hand in my business i just i don't feel
as fluid maybe i'm doing it wrong i just
didn't feel that um
the
the respawn part would have helped me on
the floor to help me the um the medic
joint it's a little bit overdone like
sometimes you i felt i got straight
murdered and then in a second later my
man pops up on the floor help help
and i'm like hey yeah
and i can't yeah the life's alert the
life of the legend
like the life of the joy i'm like i i
see what they try to do they really try
to bring the importance of the medic but
some situations it is you know very
realistic and hustle come running past
yeah
yeah this game is if you're a medic you
like to do that you use all day all
about that the last thing i can't front
though is
the polish the glitch
glitches
it looks like you know what the problem
is i i you know what and cog i just want
to jump in for a hot seat
please i think i think this is the
call of duty comes out 360 graphics yes
right you're like what what why is that
guy's face i can't that looks like
something from like
vectrex
right
tricks face
and then
and then you get into halo and you're
like yo yeah
this is
wait a second if if the multiplayer
looks this good in a beta yes the single
player's gotta be on point right
and then you get the battlefield and you
you're on a battlefield guy and i'm a
battlefield guy
and i'm looking at the videos and i'm
like
okay
i like i like the twister i think that
is amazing right i like the size big
giant maps you can run them for 10
minutes not find
anybody true
and that's fine that's fine because
that's that's battlefield conquest right
it's big yes you know you don't want to
feel you're in a vacuum
but then you start talking about what
you're talking about and then i've seen
some stuff and i'm like
is that because i'm watching it on
youtube
or is that what it actually looks like
and i get it's a beta right
but
you know
you're asking me for seventy dollars and
no single player
that that's the part right my part right
yeah
okay okay so
to to hustle's part where
halo has to have this incredible
campaign
other multiplayer said the hell would it
don't even put it
it's not necessary because people ain't
playing it right just just them old
fogey dude
they pull up the analytics exactly so
it's it's i'm sorry but they out they
outvoted you
so are you a flag that we us older
gamers are holding on to standards that
the young generation do not care about
yo i'm gonna tell you this
if this story doesn't hit
if this joint don't sell this is a
metric right to see if it's sale yeah
that's a good point i think they are
testing the metric to see if it sells
because let me tell you something that
multiplayer is going to be on infinite
that's the real infinite
okay that's the real infinite
that joint demo that that single player
if that single player don't hit say bye
bye that story gonna end right around
your head
right there and you won't get another so
i'm gonna tell you dudes right here game
pass or not you better engage with that
single player you better buy that single
player you better play it if you want
that story if you halo dudes
want that story to keep going on and
joseph all of a sudden came out of the
bushes and was like i'll fix your story
you know how it was you you said he was
drinking monetize or something
let me tell you something i know who to
blame if that story is not good but come
all the way
up a little later
already
we ain't gonna do that oh we're not
doing that that's right we're gonna say
we threw the hail mary and he had the
david tyree hold it on his head and we
ain't gonna say that all of a sudden he
came in with the bahama mama and then
and then if it's not good he don't get
the blame you dropped that ball
he already said they said that when he
came in the game
to fix it up to tighten it up if it
ain't tight all right you getting the
blade
since we do a football references
let's use it's more of to be it's more
of a
remember when um what's tony gunji had
tampa bay buccaneers
this is more of a john gruden coming and
taking the buccaneers it was already
there it was you know so he just
tightened it up and getting them over
the finish line john gruden wouldn't
have got that super bowl championship
he'd be getting that done who would have
got the blame oh john right
joseph is gonna get all his work
i'ma tell you right now if dude dude
buddy buddy dude has a little bit more
time than i like i'm blaming joseph you
know listen
hustle i'm telling you we're gonna see
we're gonna see look my last part is
before we move on it's just um yeah the
bugs were bad it was it was really good
that sucks and if they delayed it this
one once
i i am concerned like do they need more
time because then i'm hearing 20 22.
yeah i hope so and then i'm hearing like
for the other consoles like it's even
or bad like it's people are having
problems from what i understand the
playstation ones i don't know about the
consoles
okay so you just said
i bet to say the
the lower versions of each column
yeah last year
okay yeah oh
i didn't know what it was going to be
not the last correct correct correct no
you're absolutely right you have two
it's that i'm talking about like okay
basically pc lower end
also obviously the console they're
people some people are having bad
experiences you know what i mean so i
gotta be good but you are correct it
might be that playstation violence can i
say one thing before we wrap up yes yes
um hey well first i want to apologize to
the panel and the chat because i didn't
realize that battlefield was just
multiplayer that's why i brought up a
story earlier but i can also
this this was set a dangerous uh
precedent too um i can't remember where
i was when i spoke about it but if they
only focus on multiplayer you know you
said they're gonna get it up out of here
right
i you know what let me tell you why i
doubt that very seriously you know
shigeru miyamoto will never let this
happen to mario oh um
let's see uh playstation will never let
this happen to the uncharted series
right that would never let that type of
thing happen oh they won't let uncharted
come out with a multi-player without no
no no solely with the multiplayer no
because it didn't just naughty dog ain't
doing that okay okay no naughty dog
ain't doing that naughty dog
is that they're gonna have a story with
that and this this is halo's uh mario
y'all know i know i know where you go
you're going with the importance of the
franchise i'm right there
i think when he's saying he's on to
something it is super important
again
yes i'm telling you man like
dudes don't see the pharaoh [ __ ]
for the trees
is somebody in there that fought for the
campaign very hard that free to play was
up there
if they felt that if they put halo
remember they put master chief inside
fortnite right
they probably looked at the metrics and
was like mad people are playing with his
skin
a lot of people wanted to be
master chief in this
you know free to play mode
and when they went free to play it kind
of threw us all off to be honest with
you but then it kind of made sense to go
inside game pass right but then when
they removed the battery of entry for
free to play games that you didn't have
to have xbox live right
that changed everything right there that
whole thing so that means that they were
trying to get to everybody
the single-player experience
it's really we're all we're dying
dinosaurs i know where you going with
this
and i'm gonna tell you man
they would do battle passes they would
do all this stuff they would have these
guys in there they would have some weird
currency for clothes they would do all
of that stuff the single player does not
generate the level of revenue that this
multiplayer can
and if this thing don't hit you might
get a book release
[Music]
battlefields out get check it out still
a couple one day left i believe in the
video the bait
michael patton with the five dollar
super chat sean layton i can't do the
math on game pass jim ryan replied i do
king is right
okay
let's get smitty smith oh man it skipped
me it scared me hold on what's up i got
you smitty smith um
man when boom says he can't pardon me
for looking down on my phone yeah
man when boom says he canceled his
pre-order you know it's serious the book
of acts yeah and the next super chat is
from
game onyx game omix hey hey do me a
favor tell me what currency that is a
game and also um put like a a way to say
your name so i want to mess you up um
xbox is giving away eight months of game
pass for free in india due to national
banks new regulations which need xbox to
update recurring payments of recurring
payment methods yes
okay i don't know nothing about that
what currency is that i got you the next
one uh select bang 07 with gp pound
looks like uh 449 hello chap's been away
for a few weeks but always catch up on
the podcast version just want to say
that i have the lg c1 coming tomorrow
okay i can't wait god led in the
building i see you
what you got
uh big mad moe who's a member for 15
months lord bronze
hey mo you from dc i'm just curious
anyway
good morning lords hustle and good
morning lords hustle and boom thank you
sir good morning um
love what y'all doing you are an
inspiration
keep up the good work you sound like me
um let's see also hello
[Music]
is this i got hard to find also let's
see uh file some chat chill boom it's
just a preseason no need for the full
court press just yet
a little doubt um is this select bang
what's
should 343 release a limited multiplayer
on november 15th flights were good even
getting some of that would be cool for a
few weeks until the few the full release
interesting i don't know i think they
are going to do another flight though
that's what we're hearing here that's
not the last flight what else we got uh
108 dragons tv shout out to you kindness
um
good morning let the whoa whoa good
morning
baby oh god you're good you're good
you're gonna take my glasses
okay let's get the right okay that's
that's why i got tripped up good morning
let's get the record straight there
hasn't been one card to outsell halo on
microsoft on the microsoft console
effects is that true
let's see
halo 5 okay halo 5 campaign i don't know
about that one sir oh let's see halo 5
campaign was so so still five bill
generator and multiplayer the king is
back hey look i don't know if we can uh
we might have to fact check that that
first one away be in his bag won't
always be in his bags i would have been
hard-pressed to go against what away
with with his statistics
microsoft platform remember that's the
caveat that he put yeah he put on yeah
ea delayed battlefield to next year and
is dice the new bioware in terms of fall
off wow that's disrespectful though wow
disrespectful
jesus all right
um
let's see
one more we got alex is that alex
escarosa he's been a member for two
months laura brown shout out to you
thank you sir he said me if the halo
story sucks damn
anyway who hopping on that mountain
alex alex
[Laughter]
out here promoting pirating metroid come
on bro a game that came out two days ago
can we collectively stop promoting that
trash site we will not be naming names
but i know it's just i know what you're
doing
oh gamonomics shout out with the 40
indian rupees the currency is indian
foreign
that's what's up gerald mack that's my
guide to the chat or hello iop good
morning lords and panels salute celestia
thank you
do you know that he has the best xbox
live name i've ever heard i think it's
what is it
killer
gorilla yes
yes salute
yes absolutely so let's get to it this
one's solves topic i'll take it over
there is a certain nintendo title
franchise back out here in the streets
that met troy
dredd is out here it has released so i
just want to get impressions for those
who have played it so let's start with
boom because i know
boom i seen a glorious
almost like a collector's edition i see
the meatballs i seen everything boom i
was i was pocket watching boom i seen
you out there it was a lot of currency a
lot of money spent
you know this is what this is what's
great about having a birthday in
september you get those gift cards you
stock them away and you're in your
underwear drawer and you forget they
exist that's exactly how i do it so
let's talk about it man that's right how
are we feeling we we we were talking
before we went live and
there is something to be said about
nintendo
when they release
a game
now when it's first party it seems as if
the seas split apart
and they release a product that doesn't
need a 100 gig day one patch
it comes out
and it works and it works on your old
switch your new switch the oled switch
and portable on the tv screen
and metroid has returned in one of the
biggest ways
it's it's
i'll put it to this way if you've if
you've played metroid if you played
super metroid i think we all have
um
we understand the the significance of
what that title meant when it came out
on the su
you know the snes way back in the days
and what it means even to today
and then of course
back in 2017 we were people who had the
3ds we were fortunate to get a remake of
metroid 2 yes which
uh it still bothers me that it's not on
the switch like i never experienced that
because i it's just that screen is just
just
you know what i'm saying and i would
love to be able to play that on the big
screen so i'm hoping at some point we do
get that but
fast forward
almost what is it almost 20 years plus
since we got an original new metroid
title yes and they have they have done
it folks if you're if you're on the
fence about whether or not you should
drop the coin
if you're a metroid fan you got to ask
yourself why why didn't you pre-order
because
they have these things they're called
they're they're not emmys they're called
e-m-m-i's
is crazy okay
i'm gonna tell you something right now
this game
gives you those mr x resident evil 2
feelings when these things aren't
passing you
don't because
you have literally they said it that
actually uh um samus's computer tells
you you have a 99.9
chance of dying if this thing catches
you
and you can get away by hitting x but
you got to be real real grab ahold of
you though boy
and the way that they do it in the game
is this thing is like a ninja which we
have in front of us right now
it's on the wall it's on the ceiling it
just drops down
and it
there's a yellow light that it's looking
for you but when you see that red light
you know you better book
and
i gotta tell you man i'm only a couple
hours in and it is so it it is new
metroid and it's classic metroid
and that
the addition of that thing chasing you
and knowing that you only have because
you can kill them
but you can't kill them at will you have
to find this special big lady yeah
yeah and the big cannon that she gets
you get you get two shots you knock it
down it's like oh your cannon's back to
normal and you throwing bombs and and
rockets at this thing and it's going
like this
it is
really well done i i got to tell you
this is definitely again this is this is
going to be one of those game of the
year yes conversations that we're all
going to have
where something from an o.g like metroid
to something like a two-man team is
gonna be in the conversation i cannot
wait for the end of this show this game
is worth your time when you shout the
lord metroid to the chat he is like oh
boom you ain't seen nothing yet that's
what he said you're telling us
i can't wait man shout out to stitch who
gets all the set with a switch topics
you got bad bushes
sorry brother it's coming in hot you got
to deal with it brother you got to deal
with it but yo right my man hustle did
you pick it up if die or wait wait yeah
what's up so i haven't picked it up yet
but i kind of want to give uh
you guys and i want to give the chat
just uh a quick uh sad factor about uh
the metroid series in general let's go
for those you all who don't know metroid
is the worst selling intelligence
right
now why you gotta put that out down no
no i'm gonna put the battery in these
fake nintendo fans back yo pic pick it
up if you want something to go on and be
great you got to got to support it man
so this from what i understand this
story picks up from what super metroid
left off
yes i
don't know well i heard it from gamespot
and i don't you just spoil it but well
i'll just say it's a continuation from
that story
[Music]
the last one suppose and i want to say
that supposedly this is how it finishes
so
you know
[Laughter]
here's what i will say um you know first
and foremost like i don't want to say
i'm a gaming historian but i care about
game preservation that's why y'all see
me with a bunch of new stuff y'all see
me getting game cubes and all this stuff
so i'm gonna get the metroid prime
series and i'm gonna run through that
too i'm not the biggest metroid cat
because i find it annoying that you got
to get something and you can't get here
until you go back and get this other
thing and then when you go back and get
the other thing you can go up top and
but now you can go down the bottom and i
hate that
and i feel like it's bad story telling
in my humble opinion now granted i'm
gonna cut super metroid some slack okay
because you know what that title means
man but
i want this to actually succeed nintendo
has to get the message from the
consumers that yo hey we still want this
so you still got to get so i'm going to
pick it up next week
how many years has metroid been out
25 right 25 years over 20 over 20 years
sure
the message hasn't been sent for 25
years
obviously the people have spoken
to disrespect
we're not gonna do that we're not gonna
we're not gonna do that tell them i'll
talk
which is so disrespectful by the way
mansion is out here doing numbers now so
you know when they put out the new samus
joint gonna be an l like yo
literally the worst franchise they got
fat and you said they talked about in 25
years nobody found out that it was whack
your own assessment her own assessment
that fetch it here just to get up to
there and you got to go back to there
but you can't hey this corridor looks
the same but now i can go up oh right
there
i like this i like i don't understand
what it's not like this
it did not work so now they release
these emmys or mmi's emmy dudes to just
spice it up i heard they got quick time
events i heard they spicing it up
it may not work it might work but in 25
years you have been deemed the worst
like
for 25 years you have shown up to work
and you are the worst
employee there
so i'm sorry brother i'm just gonna say
this
i think he gonna continue to be the
worst
i think
she looked like they told you so you're
not picking it up okay
it's over
or you're not picking up you're not
supporting
oh no no i'm about
it was one of the hottest
no no no it's it's sadly it's not though
at least i buy it
shout out to shout out to iron mike in
the chat um thank you for correcting me
sir he says um it picks up from where
metroid fusion left off that super
metroid okay
it's it's definitely disrespectful man
like this
you talking about the franchise
i would have thinking kirby would have
been low on the totem pole like that's
kirby guy get out of here
yeah apparently i mean you know if you
whatever hey look man
shout out to him shout out to sac around
the team over there the smash brothers
they closed that super smash brothers
with an underwhelming bang so to speak
and i say underwhelming for me because
they didn't put geno in the game
obviously nobody got metroid's back
gang is coming in high bro this was one
i did not initially plan on getting i'll
be real i was like i gotta see i gotta
see as we get closer
but as we got closer i think was that
last direct and i was like nah boom
sabo side savage looking clean sounds
like a clean and i don't know what it is
i think for me i've always i think the
the character the suit looks amazing
just a stylized character i don't know
why it doesn't hit the way it's supposed
to but i think it's a series that always
spoke to me like i don't really care as
a nintendo person like i don't care for
the curvy stuff i'm gonna be honest i've
never been that guy i've always felt
like i've connected more with the metric
even in smash that's the character i
would take but um yeah look boom said it
best the classic 2d vibes you know
cinematic narrative experience boom
awesome very small dramatic very cut
scene-y you know when it when all this
you know storytelling the robot's
telling you what happened in the planet
hey chances of survival is this that's
to the third you know i know i know
hustler don't like the the backtracking
you know what i'm saying but they kind
of created the genre metroid
like they are the fathers of the style
that everybody now is run with you know
and probably be more more popular than
metroid but i think what's dope for me
is the reason why it doesn't bother me
in metroid because i always feel like
even from back in the day you know you
get an ability all right now she could
roll like a ball go through this area
okay now you get a new ability like
bulma saying you get the big cannon you
know boom you can attack certain enemies
stuff like that the thing for me though
and boom said it best
where i fell in love with this one
is the dread
the fear
like that thing coming at you this on
this what is it the enemy whatever we
calling them yeah that thing is no joke
and when you finally get real i was up
against the wall when they were chasing
me i was i was trying to get the cannon
out i was like
i tried able to
you know it felt you know what it really
took me back to the vibes of terminator
1
trash compactor final scene like you
know when it's right on her like what
the
it felt that energy you know
they got it man they got it's really
it's i can't believe they they knocked
it out the park the boss fights are epic
there's one complaint though and not a
king is gonna laugh kick probably ain't
gonna care when you're gonna laugh 480p
besides we know what you're getting with
this low res but
we we know again but it's one conflate
though
nintendo i gotta call y'all out man i
got
boom
what is with every major nintendo
franchise why does the amiibo have to
have some gameplay changing giving you
health giving you rockets giving you
literally if any other game company did
this
right where they release a master chief
amiibo and every day you play you get
more health every day you get more
weapons than the average guy like like
how does nintendo get away with like
what is the skyward sword you get free
traversal like how did they get away
from yeah
[Music]
you're definitely on to something uh i
will say this the loft wing amiibo
giving you the ability to fast travel
did that that's egregious i i but i
bought it
can i ask you a question does it give
you a competitive advantage
in the game yes no it doesn't you know
why not single player because there's a
single player again
single player so if i can buy a toy
it for a game a single player it it
gives me unlimited potions daily potions
daily survivability you could choose
bro call of duty had a toy
listen i gotta give is the caveat they
found the sweet spot first they and
first and foremost they are a toy maker
oh here we go okay
second they continue to support a
function that is worthy of the tech that
they have uh-huh right so again the toy
is form and function people
okay
you give me that and listen you and you
wrongly
not to
in you because you know you can afford
all these crazy above
that nobody can find so that you can
have an advantage sir
yes yes i choose oh man
i choose i will say though that the
advantages for metroid prime are kind of
dope you can get the you know
one once per day
the health
and
and you can get the extra rockets and
you know
these are hilarious but shout out to
metroid it is hot it's out here i'm
gonna go all the way back for before we
get the new joints um it's a me easy
um hi 5 canadian i believe hi everyone
quick question for all on the panel do
you guys really believe that we will
hear official news about a microsoft
acquisition this year when we did yeah
yeah
yeah
before the before the year is out all
right awesome yes no yes i mean that
writing has been on the wall for quite
some time i think if we do hear
something i thought we would have heard
something at tgs but now we didn't so i
figured
yeah
i mean well if they would have bought a
uh country
in the land of the horizon sun they
definitely would have been but i think
we hear something that e3 next year
but i'm not sure i'm not sure if it's
the publisher announced this year or at
xo 21 do we get an e3 2018 thing where
there's multiple
developers no doubt
i think it's happening i just don't know
which one it is no doubt shout out to
what's up okay i'm sorry i i honestly
believe sorry
i honestly believe
before the next uh fiscal period yeah
which is more announced yeah no i'm with
you i'm with you yeah yeah before so so
that yeah so you know what it might slip
to next year because right before the
next call earnings and and and fiscal
release then it might because
acquisitions has to be done before that
period you know to tie it up shout out
shout out to jeff grubb we had him on
defining duke he kind of alluded that
there's money that needs to be spent
that's allocated for acquisitions and if
they don't use it that the price will go
up and from a percentage whether it's
going on
the price going up so you know how that
goes okay anyways explain some shout out
to split difference but the crest up for
splendiferous slow mo backslap with the
technology
everything nintendo does is bushes until
they can release hardware that isn't
obsolete for a decade new oled allows
you to see the fps better gave you
bluetooth and a firmware update four
years later
and they're still
winning and they're still with the mpd's
they dominate the generation i gotta say
what we gotta say
i took my knees yeah they took [ __ ]
everybody man it's crazy what nintendo's
doing iron mike the boxer two dollar
super chat it picks up from fusion
that's a bird thank you for correcting
us thank you thank you sir and then don
otaku two thousand chat was it king
capping for ori hmm
king do you have anything to say for
yourself
yeah he said orion uh
i guess he tried to foreign although he
tries to say you disrespect for the
nintendo i guess it must be a shot must
be a subliminal i don't understand what
that even means because anything inside
game pass i can't pull oh my god lloyd
metroid being very disrespectful two
dozen chat king get in his ball head
sucked by a metroid stop okay oh that
sounds crazy that sounds crazy first
first i got to say paul's dead
to you
if you even
took the time out to visualize it and
then you wrote that down and then you
press send with money
timeout
pulse
savage shout out to gabe gabenomics my
man indian rupees 100 dollars you know
what i'm saying people in the us under
underestimate game pass a lot in india
game pass is the reason a lot of people
shifted from ps to xbox i know at least
11 people who did wow that's interesting
and it's cool
it's interesting to hear from other
regions right to see
the game pass effect so shout out to
gamer now it's giving us some good
knowledge from indian region that's
what's up
spartan go 17 two pounds super chat
dance move went in on that game pass
money boy starving talk about that
tomorrow
so goodbye we going to talk about it i
think we caught up that i missed any um
let me know if i missed any i thought i
was good
i think i'm up today all right cool
let's get it let's get it pushed let's
get it pushing so we got this uh next
topic man another big one
jim ryan king jim ryan he's outside man
and i'll set it up for you if you like
um go for that yeah man jim brian who's
in the news is in a big interview with
uh industry games industry.biz i believe
we have a show uh gi live
and um jim ryan was there talking about
playstation talking about everything was
going why is king's hat that way
right before i jim ryan make a move
make a move you know jim ryan definitely
looking over at the playstation nation
he says you know what
you're not enough
you need more booty
let me let me read the chrome the pirate
i am the captain of this ship
captain let me read the quote first sir
you're clearly about to get in your bag
so
it was a very very eventful comments
that he made it referenced in his
interview and then he said yeah they
asked him you know for all the game
future of gaming
where do you hope for the future of
playstation and he said i want to see a
world where the games that we make at
playstation can be enjoyed by many
tens of millions of people perhaps
hundreds of millions right now success
with the current console model a really
great place you hit you're only talking
10 or 20 million people being able to
play that game we're talking about games
stacking up against movies music and
movies they can be enjoyed by almost
limitless audiences and i think some of
the art that our studios are making is
the finest entertainment they've made in
the world then he continues to go on to
gate the audience for that at 20 or only
30 million
frustrates me
i would like to see a world where
hundreds of millions of people can enjoy
these games so this set twitter ablaze
there's a lot of you know controversial
master chief just came in because he
wanted to hear this personally
you're ridiculous so king this is your
time i'm gonna let you set it off what
do you take from jim ryan's commenter he
said i'm the captain of the ship here
you playstation brothering
you have been purchasing our hardware
yes that's good that's good buy more buy
more again why the hell is microsoft
still around why the hell is microsoft
still next to us
why we outsell them
we got better games
how the hell can microsoft compete with
us
we can't sell more games we don't have a
reach
we need a reach okay i want to reach 100
million people
i cannot reach 100 million people with a
current model is it because you only
have uh 2.8 million sales in uh
playstation now as opposed to 31 million
sir
i can't say this right i say you're dead
i told you old boy was complicit
you did i told you he was in pocket i
told you he was a numbers dude
i told you
he's dead in my heart with nexus
he's your guys
this is the last playstation
you don't believe me he looked at your
model and said what you doing is not
enough
i want to reach the millions
i want to reach 100 million
i want to get beyond these walls let's
get this off it's not working out for us
like we thought it was an exclusive day
so
that exclusive stuff is in your head
so what he said is how can i get this i
want to get our games
what he's what listen
you gotta listen to the word the
verbiage yeah
they switched and made they self
sony studios oh
okay remember that
when you put that studio there that's a
stamp
right like burger king you see the logo
have you ever been inside like a um a
gas station
and going up the highway or whatever and
you see a burger king burger inside the
little warm up you know how the hell
burger king
that's a wobble you got a waffle
me yo this is this a real burger king
wobble yeah man it's a real burger king
i can get that
are you implying to getting the name
brand of something at other locations at
other places that we're doing
well
he did see the metrics with uh
a little known baseball game
that showed the biggest numbers that
it's had
in years
he has to reach as as a businessman
he has to reach the people that he has
him he's tired of talking to you tired
of taking you out he's tired of one and
dying in the same person
jim liked that new stuff
jim looking across the street
[Laughter]
is that that gift where the guy's
walking with his girl and he's like this
yeah
yes yes savage savage so you dudes
really think jim love you
jim is lusting for the hundred millions
and so when when phil dominance maximus
are really a spencer spoke these words
to you that he's trying to hit the
billions you see your man shot low
your man said 100 million you know why
because he didn't want to scare you i
mean it would scare you
feeling afraid to make you afraid
phil is not afraid to make you
uncomfortable he said billions because
that's the number he's going for those
three billion people with them cell
phones in a pocket he wants you every
time you pick up your phone he wants
your grandmama playing free halo
but jim dance moves ryan ain't gonna
tell you because he don't want to scare
you so so so you are you reply this is a
subtle
thing easing them into it he's grooming
them
but he told you
your efforts aren't helping the cause
[Music]
and i need to get bigger better bolder
and if i need to put my games on game
pass who the hell kids if last of us
comes out in game pass right now who
really cares
but if it sells inside game pass the
engagement is up inside game pass if it
goes in steam if it goes in um
an epic store
it sells they need to make money so
selling to you same 10 million people
that none of y'all are really buying
games anyway let's keep it a buck let's
keep it a buck it's 10 million out there
so there's not no 10 million games so he
literally said what you say it's funny i
gotta cut you for a second because the
comment
i know you you you've been getting a lot
of flack when you when you go in on the
playstation exclusive sales right and a
lot of the fans like yo it's so tasty
success or whatever but it is
interesting you're in your swami bag
right now because it is interesting to
see
him say exactly like he said a really
great playstation hit you're talking 10
or 20 and he doesn't seem satisfied with
that like he does not seem satisfied and
then the key word king is what you say
which is what he says to gate the
audience when you say gate the audience
meaning like the console
is not enough
the verb is the verbiage is very clear
[Laughter]
you guys are not enough
you really think y'all enough we sold
you you're not enough he's not satisfied
with you
he's trying to bust out of those balls
pause
he's trying to get all over he's trying
to make sure that that playstation brand
is everywhere and why not and i know you
guys are sitting there saying king
you're reaching again i reach a lot and
i always hit my mark i'm 96 percent
right all the time
i'm telling you now
if it's already an install base of 31
million
and you can get your game into that tap
that vein right there yeah
why not yeah absolutely absolutely let's
open it up but this is interesting
discussion you know obviously in the
xbox community you know it was a slight
pushback i've ever felt but not too much
but you know this i think has been a
point of contention in the playstation
community this has been something where
you know exclusives matter and we're not
saying they don't right but as far as
you know limiting it only their games to
the playstation ecosystem so i'm gonna
give it to you boom like when you hear
these comments from jim ryan like
where does this take you where do you
think he's going with this like what
what do you make of these comments
well i mean let's just bring in the
numbers and and both hustle and king and
yourself uh are a number of guys just
like myself uh it cost well over 100
million dollars
to make the last of us too
that does not count
the amount of monies that went into the
advert we know that at least
in in advertising
you know they're spending 30 40 50
million dollars to get it on buses and
trains and planes and put on commercials
right so to make the game it was a
hundred million dollars
how much with interest do they how many
copies do they have to sell well they i
can assure you they did not sell enough
of the less of us to uh to make back
that money now whether they took a loss
whether they broke even we'll never know
we're not that we're not gonna be
encounters right the problem
with sony's uh
you know overall opinion prior to this
is that they are an exclusive brand
and as we know this world is inclusive
it is an inclusive brand you have to be
a part of the conversation
everyone must be available for that
conversation that's why i love microsoft
and because they're they push
being inclusive not exclusive right it's
one of the reasons why i really dig the
brand
when you re and it's funny because you
know jim doesn't do himself
any favors when he constantly goes out
of his way not this interview but in two
interviews before where he's taking
shots right or at microsoft specifically
xbox game pass and you see this
interview
and it really does put him in a sour
light
like we understand he's a businessman we
understand that he's got a
listen
playstation fans if that's your brand i
could tell you without being joking like
king was saying
you're just not enough
okay
you're just not enough because you know
what the problem is with a lot of these
big
these big mouths they play twitter and
not games oh that part yeah okay
i i've been to
i've been accused of being an xbox guy
yet i buy every collector's edition of
every sony first party game
right my playstation 5 collection i can
i can tell you out does any one of these
i was talking about
i was i was in the cutlass
yeah no but but but because i'm a video
game fan man and i love sony for their
first party games but the the reality is
their fans
are just not enough now spider-man is a
conundrum spider-man is 20-plus million
seller because it's spider-man right the
game with 2018 spider-man was fantastic
morales fantastic
i i i missed it but we'll get to it in a
second
um i will say this
this does not surprise me because i have
we've all had this conversation time and
time again they're leaving money on the
table it's crazy that it has taken this
long and you know something
there's no doubt
that jim ryan's going like this to phil
spencer
because 31 million now listen you can
say that's true you can say it's false i
gotta be honest with you when the take
two ceo says a number yeah
it's hard to be like yeah that guy made
a mistake that's the ceo of tv that was
interesting and he said well you know
what i'm saying yeah that was weird
so
there it it it's it's pretty hard to
fathom
that sony isn't going to pivot to make
more money it just it just
put that back up
he said
i wasn't going to say that because i
didn't want to take this down but he
said if i recall and i watched that
video several times in slow motion
someone did it said hey phil we are at
30 million yeah he did he did it's very
very interesting but when i say we i
think team
before i give it the hustle i want to
ask you this question boom um
you know so obviously
i guess the thing that's surprising is
how
bold he is at being and transparent with
it because generally let's be honest the
base has been resistant to opening the
borders so to speak on the exclusive
titles and things like like that king is
laughing at least
so my question is do you think like what
avenue do you think it takes do you
think it takes like okay are we doing um
you know moving that now more
aggressively to pc or is this mobile
like what avenue does this take because
he clearly the 10 million
for the playstation exclusive is not not
satiating him it's not satisfying him
right so
where do you think he takes it as far as
this i think he takes it where his board
members tell him to go don't go
all right his board members are telling
him hey listen you put out a couple of
playstation five exclusives you you
can't get the console to everyone and we
took a bath on x y and z
and that's just not cutting it
there's a reason why
all of these og playstation games uh you
know ips like god of war and horizon and
and and the rest of them are going to
eventually be on playstation 4 because
you have to make the money
listen this is this is not surprising
but again it does put jim in a bad light
because this is not what he was talking
about only about a month a month or two
ago and now he's going back look the
reality is this playstation fans here
comes the band-aid ripping rip it's day
and dates to wherever it's gonna go and
you're just gonna have to you're just
gonna have to suck it because that's
business
okay so his new name once that happens
it's gonna be worldwide gym
worldwide worldwide
it ain't gonna be dance
the streets and the streets is for
everybody
i do want to say this um shout out shout
out to phil spencer because when they
first initiated everything in terms of
putting xbox games on pc will start
there right when they first initiated
that it caught a little heat right
the best thing they could have done for
me was putting this game on pc because i
got another way to play it yes jim ain't
playing with y'all so now we look at
game plays okay so look now we look at
game pads right now the 30 31 million
number
i'm not going to say that it's true or
false but phil spencer could have
corrected him what he's what phil
spencer said in the interview was he
said the last time we reported it was 18
minutes right right so you're not wrong
but we just yeah that was very pr very
pr so so first of all uh ceo would take
two slow down a little bit don't put our
business down
oh that was the translation
the third thing i want to say is um in
the words of damon wayne's uh mo money
mo money mo listen if y'all crazy if
y'all we saw all this stuff coming to pc
the second we saw what was that horizon
zero dawn and people made a big big
shout out to my homie jack move johnny
he made a whole thing about it
it's over i said oh nice over it's a
wrap now maybe we might we may not get
these games day one but according to
this report my man said hundreds of
millions and he really meant he really
meant billions for real because if we
are going to take that xbox model that
phil expensive motto look we're putting
it on the phone though yeah this is
right there we have a topic um got to
cut you um hustle i did have a topic not
too long ago that i was bringing to the
realm you remember that topic cog when i
was talking about on playstation games
going to the cell phone yes yes
continue sorry i do apologize but i did
have that topic we showed that topic
yeah because the topic was dated right
but it's it's relevant again
yeah ain't nobody look nobody can they
write my and jimmy he is a jimmy i'm
gonna call him
jimmy jimmy is a businessman he do care
about the numbers man hey look
shout out to all the playstation fanboys
on twitter on youtube you're not good
enough
yo you you're not good enough it don't
matter oh yeah we so you know how many
councils we sold right we might say we
hit 80 million right we playstation's
over 80 million costumes only 10 million
of y'all bought it that's not good
enough
we need more of this no no we need more
of this oh wait y'all want to play on
the left
on the phone
you can play on the tv we can play it we
can play it on the phone you can play it
on your tablet all right look we wait
how much money how much money still on
the making kid all right cool we on that
too yo he saw a field goal
wait a second they only sold seven
million we sold ten how come i ain't get
a yacht
how come i can get it
that's that that's that billion dollar
talk that's how i go there man
that's when jim said okay now that's
enough for this
it's enough for this
i'm
i've seen this coming for a long time
maybe not the phone thing so much so
like when i saw when i saw that
interview when you sent it to me though
i was like oh
oh if it wasn't over before if you
didn't think you lost your girl before
she gone she's she's she is for
everybody it is over it doesn't mean
that the quality right of something like
this will change no question it doesn't
mean that the quality is going to change
per se it means a whole lot more money
coming in it means a lot more
opportunities i actually am looking
forward to this for like the indie
people who are around who are you know
are in game pass right who are in
playstation now like they get the
they get the best benefit out of that we
you know aerial knights never yell it's
probably one of my you know favorite
games you see it's only about an hour
and a half but i got to take the time to
like do that because this gentleman made
this game by itself
if it's on phones and it's all
playstation and it's on xbox and so on
and if it's everywhere and everybody see
it you're not you you get to it so as an
indie developer all day but nah jimmy
jimmy want that bread though he wants
that money he wants that money money
he's gonna get it and he's gonna get it
much more to be said i mean king would
probably just laugh at what he saw this
news because this is what he's been
saying for so long boom said things so
eloquently yeah i mean it just comes to
show you there's a difference between
you know the fanboyism
and the boardroom right and the
fanboyism and the pride and we get it
you know we we're never going to
disrespect to say playstation hasn't
been successful we're never going to
stay and say that you know these games
are hidden and these quality exclusives
but the reality is it's like you know
hustle said like in his mind
that's not enough you know like king
said like he said yo that's not enough
and the only way i could visualize them
improving and increasing this scope is
bringing these games to pc bringing
these games to mobile you know doing
what you got to do cloud streaming
services that stuff on xbox
i don't know if it's going there but if
i get a hold of god of war on my xbox
you guys better run
yeah you will be popping bottles i know
yeah
it's it's i think for me the interesting
thing charting jim ryan
is each time they speak to him the
bolder he gets
yeah because let's be honest you know
the playstation community is a very
[Laughter]
they're very passionate you know
community and you know they take things
very seriously so even
remember put it this way hustle remember
why we get twitter seriously yeah
if they took it seriously they buy a
game
listen remember like we would watch the
shows and demon souls were in and it'd
be this curious mistake coming to pc at
the bottom oh no no that was that was a
mistake you know and i'm like there's no
way there's a mistake like that's
already done you just wasn't ready so
what it is it is like a grooming it is
like a we gotta get them on board slowly
because we know a lot of we're light
betting
a lot of people are resistant but this
is the direction they're going to me
it's clear as day it's clear that and
the way i look at it is like yo if it's
if it's going to help playstation get
more money to allow them to have more
sequels and you know bring the games
that we wanted to get out the console
business they putting out these
high-priced weak consoles let's just get
past this and let's get these to
everyone
look at the end of the day i get you i
get it but it's like at the end of the
day
he did say a good point it's gated the
the weight shout out to sean layton he
even said it recently shout out to barry
on the persona yeah on the what's up
playstation podca he said it like
there's only a certain amount of money
in that box even if you're the best you
get all there's a box on that console
speed there's a ceiling right
after a while it's like yo with the the
horizon cost the games the way things is
and development you can't afford these
things to flop and not get that back and
you trying to hit more so even if it
means yo let the pc community eat you
know let them get a taste of what's
going on here gigging stupid kick kick
cause you really clearly
no i'm just with you
i'm paying the mom and everything
like i said just even if they get on pc
people want to eat and more people want
to get a hold of these games and you're
seeing it with the tvs as well and
implementation things like that so
this is where it's going y'all this is
where it's going the key for me the
curious thing for me and my last point
will move on is i want to see if they do
anything with the playstation now
or the ps plus model if anything changed
because we know the last thing that a
lot of people are holding on to
obviously is day-to-day i'm not there
yet they did it called crunchyroll
look maybe they do
since you like watching stuff
oh my god anyways so look let me read
these super chats as we move on drunk
and ninja five super chat good afternoon
lords another wonderful sunday watching
y'all love being here and big shout out
to kai the coolest person i know salutes
blessings
we have uh we have a
channel member um lord
meyer hoof yeah i hope i got that right
you got it
let's see he's been a member for two
months thank you for your support um if
we change the brand name
it's almost
what it's almost with phil dominance
maximus
really is i'm not what's in the king i i
i do wanna know justice i really don't
thank you sir a really good spencer
uh said long ago yes sir um the next one
is from game onyx yep i hope i got that
right yep
we have uh gaming onyx thank you let's
see we have we have wait
okay we have is
no ps now in india
after being a problem okay so what we
have now okay so they were promised oh
wow they don't have it in india they
don't have ps now in india that that
sucks actually let me get one away it
makes that makes it make sense and now
there's been a big turnover the game
pass yeah it's been it's actually now i
gotta jump you get one away because i
got jumped
i was about to remember they didn't jump
me so if you want to grab it for me it
would be appreciated too
you gotta walk away hustle yeah cause i
was grabbing then it just jumped me
okay cool um since people like shout out
to 108 dragons tv y'all make sure y'all
support him as well
since people like pop pocket watching
watch this 30 million times
dollars a month for game pass don't do
ultimate let's aim at entry price
let's okay let's aim at the entry price
let's see
peeps in the chat
hold up peeps in the chat type in the
answer please jim knows numbers that's
why
microsoft
still around facts okay i i butchered
that my phone my favorite user he was
shorthanding a lot of stuff i gotta get
used to reading
you good you're good you're good okay um
laughing is the cure that's a good name
i like that um
hold on make sure i get this right so
that's why they hired
jim
ryan
xbox game pack
blueprint and
eventually ea and eventually ea access
ubisoft play will be add on both
services that that's something that's
happening i've been waiting for that
i've been waiting for that you you you
play yeah
because i have not purchased any of the
last assassin's creeds on purpose
nothing i think i'm caught up now oh is
that parasite green yeah
yeah now you gotta pick up caught up now
because now five pounds super chat i
remember listening to royce and m scary
movie while driving in liberty city and
gta 3 but would take
wb i would take wb over take two for a
new batman and mortal kombat versus
killer instincts
the problem with spider-man in any other
marvel game sony makes is what happens
when disney say why is the game only
here
yeah well he said that put it over there
what you're gonna say no
that you're gonna go anywhere you got
the license jonathan b the home we
haven't seen that name in a minute shout
out to y'all they've been fighting out
some chat i just want to know when did
jim ryan turn into beady man he saw
those movie shows of us and said panda
replay
yes sir yes sir remixer selector rewind
let me know what happened let me know
what happened put it put it at me in the
uh in the chat so we oh
yeah super chat again laughing at the
killer files i don't think sony will put
their exclusives day one i think they'll
release six months after release that
hey you can still get money on the back
end that way you know what i'm saying
after the you know things satiating i
know i know it doesn't hurt this is see
this is the
thing what what does it hurt to put your
stuff because at that point in time
everybody already talked about it
everybody already did all the stuff they
became studios for a reason they're
hiring all these studios and stuff like
this for a reason
they hired nexus for a reason
you know they purchased these these
these studios they got these studios to
put these things into place there's no
reason for you to have a full blown
bugatti inside your garage and for you
not to hit that highway that has no
speed limit and go do that so don't tell
me or they're going to wait six months
to go drive their car no they're going
to drive that car right now
all right so
day in day is gonna what does it do to
you like it just allows you to purchase
it someplace else i just think the model
is their model is different because
their model is so
on the console yeah they're using an
older model right jim just told you it
was old and this is not working and i
don't care about your thoughts like he
just literally told you we've been
getting this all for what
because you dudes
ain't doing what i'm supposed to jim
leaves a yacht
that's what this is about yo this is
about that he saw phil's
yachting like i don't know did he get a
yeah i got to get a yacht too
i'm not getting this stuff no more he
was so bold with telling you it was
gated off that y'all are not enough it's
oh i want the 100 million
you know it's funny we wouldn't even be
having this conversation if 40 and 50
million playstation owners bought their
first party games right this would not
be a conversation
the reason why we're having this
conversation is because there's 114
million consoles for the playstation 4.
and only 20 let's say 25 million of you
which is less than a quarter
support what spider-man 2018 which which
again
that just goes to show you that if
spider-man which is a world-renowned
brand for both sony and marvel
sells only 25 million to 114 million uh
consumers
the last of us two sells
13
14 let's just say 18 million 18 million
what happened to the other 94 million
console owners
on twitter
on twitter
i get what you say in relation to the
console space it's good you know i'm not
trying to poo-poo the number like it's
bad no no no no no
you're right in terms of the overall
picture and that's what king has always
he's always been consistent he's always
been on his square that he don't respect
a lot of people talk about you know all
this
the exclusive being such a dominant
thing when you look at these other
franchises the call of duty or whatever
that's the madness whatever that's
selling more in ratio with the base
right how many is out there and it looks
like yeah you know big boardroom is
talking and and ryan has transformed
whether people like him or not you know
he had that interview was very
interesting he had a good discussion
about how how bad it was in europe how
ken katarugi the father of playstation
called him into the room and said fix
your inefficient business
and
yeah it was cold-blooded it was cold
blood and he did both legs he went in
there and he said you're not producing
and i told you once you get this dude
into chop down mode
some of your favorite studios that you
be claiming is all hitters
are not and the numbers don't lie jim
looks at the numbers he looks at
performance if you're not hitting you're
going to get benched i don't care well
yeah yeah i mean look is it true
i think he i think he lost the pinky
he's got the ear at the end of the day
he's got this let's finish with the
super chat centric h with the 10 on
super chat
compliant
yes
we know what that means
from this from with this from jim ryan
do you see ps now becoming more like
game pass or playstation putting game
pass on their platform in some way okay
structure is not the same they cannot do
it in that manner why go build a
houseman you could just go across the
street in airbnb microsoft gamepads it
doesn't make any sense for you to fix an
infrastructure in a bad house just go
right across the street put your
furniture in that house because why it's
good over there i i disagree i disagree
i disagree with the ladder let's go
they're not they're not they're not
going to put game pass on there like all
right look i don't know oh no no no no
no what's up i did not say that you're
going to put game pass on playstation i
was answering the question oh okay yeah
cause he was asking should they put game
players on their platform in some way
they're all gonna do that
they're not gonna do that nintendo not
gonna do that even though nintendo and
microsoft but they're not gonna do that
they're definitely not gonna do that i'm
just saying
i think that um because we saw this back
in 2013.
i think it was 2013. we saw that we saw
this type of movement back then it just
wasn't implemented properly right so
when i said earlier like when you see it
on your phone you're gonna sit on your
tv they're going to find a way to
implement it there and as a matter of
fact aren't they working with the uh
microsoft yeah
in the background yeah they brought some
transistors from them and we gave them
some of the services because they need
service we needed transistors and they
needed servers
so we helped them out and guess what we
doing we're helping them exit the
console business
you already got the service you really
don't need to be selling stuff
you just try to promote your narrative
sir anyway moving on splendiferous two
dollars of a chat jim said why is phil
stakes bigger than mine
savage oh shout out to jose rivera this
is bull twenty awesome chat
king one supreme follow super chat once
day and date happens we need that
compilation of sony stands and twitter
spaces make it happen
elizabeth
god bless you let's see i'm going to do
a spaces
that's what you gonna do you could when
they do day to day
[Laughter]
stream has been more exciting than ever
they didn't show the event lab stuff but
sheer size of the stadium incredible no
doubt
raiden blade five pound super chat
gamers you need to understand software
is king consoles make no money why waste
money on r d when you can deliver it
without get out of your feelings oh my
god jesus
let's we'll see what happens but i do
think there's places where consoles are
still needed but that's me spartan ghost
17 two pound super chat jimbo pulling up
the game pass with that god of war
okay
nah one away dragon my man find out
super chat brooklyn stand up dragons
then the answer is 300 mil a month so
when people say game cap game pass is
not sustainable laugh out loud jim sees
that bag and sony wants in but 70 70 mil
would do for now facts no doubt
gamonomics 40 off what i like
rupees or by the way game pass ultimate
is ten dollars in india no doubt yeah
that's crazy donna tackle five chad
nintendo's the only one doing the
numbers to support the old model that's
true
crazy as far as that first party
exclusive that's very interesting
with the consoles which is really
redundant
oh shout out to my man dj orals he just
got that snap back got to get the hat
for your birth oh happy boy day official
birthday happy birthday let me know when
that birthday go down sir that's my
destiny brother right there salute to
him you already know spartan goes to be
said that uh oh lord this guy's 17 200
chad jim row your boat ryan is tired of
paddling to work
we all have a box we like but how many
companies would still be around had we
have services like these real gamers
need to change buy everything okay yeah
that's right or just get game pass and
wait for it to come out and just do that
shout out oh shout out to the shot
podcast oh my homie fuzzy fuzzy
belvedere love fuzzy man 114 114 million
consoles don't equal 114 million players
many of us have had multiple ps4s don't
forget epic is their pc gateway no
doubt so let's move into they got they
got stock in there
let's move into this last time that
y'all would get out of here with this
last one this is an important one so
shout out to king for bringing up i will
set it up for you king if you you if you
like sir
yes please yeah man chinese chinese
government is in the news and this is
kind of important normally i hope you
don't touch too many in the political
stuff but when it gets to
gaming i think it needs to be talked
about so uh yeah it looks like they are
set to crack down on video games with
content that state deems immoral
according to a leak meme and i believe
memo excuse me uh the south china
morning post the details the type the
content the government regulators will
no longer approve
this includes a games that include
same-sex relationships or effeminate
males as well as games in which a
character's gender is not immediately
apparent if regulators can't tell the
character's gender immediately the
setting of the characters could be
considered problematic and red flags
will be raised as memo states and the
second will be games that allow players
to make moral choices between good and
evil paths are also on the chopping
block some games have blurred moral
boundaries the memo states players can
choose to be either good or evil but we
don't think games should give game
players that choice and this must be
altered so king this is you i'ma let you
set it off you know this is something
obviously that we've kind of alluded to
in the past with
chinese government involvement in gaming
so
well they don't share our same views
they don't have freedom of speech in
that same manner right
all right so
um i'm going to go
and pivot into a different direction oh
blueberry team
22 of bluebertine was purchased by
tencent yep
where is tencent based
in china yeah yeah
okay so um the government has told
tencent to curb their spending
and they hit them with heavy sanctions
not too long ago and they you know
tencent lost a group of money but for
them it's like a wet wednesday it don't
matter you know really don't matter you
ain't stopping my cash flow blood so it
don't matter
um
but what's problematic is tencent really
doesn't go out and purchase the whole
studio they purchase um a controlling
share a large enough stake
that they have a voice
right
and
if their government is telling them that
they don't want these type of games or
games
that doesn't follow
their
ideology their beliefs their uh
government structure
then tencent will be forced to implement
that in games
and companies that they own shares in
they own
shares and tons of companies that you
have no idea and i told you always be
careful for the guy that comes and he
brings the bag and says i don't want
nothing from you now
[Laughter]
facts
fast just left the bag of money and he
said okay okay so so what i got to do
for this my man mm-hmm
nothing man go ahead go ahead
so you mean i could pay my mortgage get
my lights on i can feed my family buy
some clothes i got some gas money i
could do all this at the third but my
man my man what what do i owe you man
because you're saving me right now i
really this is crazy what can i do what
can i do
i don't need nothing right now i'll let
you later my dude i got to go right now
mm-hmm i got to go i got i'm busy over
here thanks for saving me
yeah but yo we'll be in touch
you good though we go you good that's
all you need you don't need nothing else
no i'm good thank you so much yeah and
then the white paper slide up under your
door they're like what is this
what you mean
feminine
yep
what happens when they say they don't
like certain races and games
and when they don't like certain uh
ethnicities
and all this other stuff and we already
had heard uh you know stuff with uh
certain things
uh certain races not being in games um
so when you go to your created character
and you create a character color isn't
in that creative character you can
create a character here type is it in
that or what happens when they start
stereotyping certain races to just look
like this or to just look like that and
and how does this transform our gaming
experience when they have they tend
trills
so deep in such
many companies that i told you guys be
very careful of the white walkers and
y'all just didn't know who i was talking
about now i told you before it was 10
cent the whole time
that's bars man this bar is a very
important subject obviously you know we
we try to talk about things and pertain
in the gaming and this is now affecting
gaming right well you just
generally stays clear of this kind of
stuff but we got to be honest this is
now affect the game we it has to be
talked about let's
switch let's get hustle first and i got
you blind i just wanted to hustle like
where are you at with this like when you
when you're hearing you know things like
that and you know affecting maybe game
development and game design and maybe
games being screened as as far as what
type of content they have in it
all right i'm gonna break this down just
from a creative standpoint um i've been
creating since i was around 18. used to
rap you just try to do different things
imagine being a rapper submitting the
versions like now this ain't good enough
no you can't say this you got to say
that over there in china and i don't see
i i almost don't even want to comment on
it for real but they kind of control
what they people
they control like the propaganda over
there yep this is something that you can
look up on your own i'm not trying to be
controversial
this is censorship at its finest and if
you know anything about me man like look
i understand we got rules on this
podcast so there's no profanity what
have you i'm cool with that but in terms
of if if you were to say if cognitive
was to say house you can't be hustled
right i would not be over here
i promise if anybody would tell me i
would not be over here so now you run
into a situation to where
oh
a feminine male mm-hmm no no no but we
don't want our people saying that
oh oh
a woman kissing another woman oh no one
won't see that america's another man
want to see they like
i don't want to bring them up and get
that good facts
wouldn't exist it wouldn't exist like
and i want to bring this up too fairly
recently i want to say like six months
ago um there was a ban in china for
children and teenagers who can only play
the game like three hours a week yes
yeah like they really just put that down
and yeah now granted twitch has their
own version
of excuse me china has their own version
of twitch yeah for those of you who
don't know the name escapes me i know i
did a video on it once upon a time but
they have their own like everything they
have their own google they have their
own youtube but they kind of control
everything so this is i'm being real
with you man like a lot of times can't
you say the best you got to be watched
you got to be careful about who you take
money from yeah they helped you but at
the same time
what did you really give up at that
point yeah yeah like you get you pretty
much i want to say soldier songs i don't
want to make it seem that diet but at
the same time
you know if you can't be yourself and
make bread
don't make the bread you keep your
integrity at that point i know it's a
lot of money
that's right that's right my grandma's
telling me that all the time i know the
money is dead but i know it's just
people looking looking around like
is it possible for the government to
even get involved with what tencent is
doing because y'all brought it up
earlier they're buying majority stakes
in a lot of these companies yeah
and if man look hello and i'm not saying
don't support them support what you like
i'm just saying
we got to be careful in terms of the
sensors like the censorship thing is
going to bother me yeah yeah like it's
that censorship thing man
i know that you know this is i think
this is like new to china in particular
because they're just getting consoles
right i think for like the first time i
do believe about if that research that i
did was was right this is like their
first like foray into it so when xbox
you see xbox you'll see playstation over
there when we see them over there the
official joints
just
be on your pivot your hair got to be on
the swivel over there and i wouldn't say
deprive certain people of a thing but
their government is actually going to
deprive you of an uncharted 5 because
well it's speculated that chloe and
nadine are going to have be romantically
involved speculated room on my part of
course i'm not an insider but if they're
not gonna allow that that mean you're
not gonna get that you're gonna miss out
yeah yeah like that that to me like that
that hurts me as a creator just in
particular right it just it is
is it's like a threatening thing to wear
like yo you can't tell people how to
create their art whether you agree with
it or not you can't tell people how to
do that man and
it's really it's it's just uh man this
is it's disheartening and i don't know
anyone over in china sadly but that's
disheartening to what they what they're
missing out on right now granted you
know the real ones man they're going to
find a way to
you know get that jack sparrow on it and
play the game anyway they want to play
the real wasn't going to do that yeah
but
you got to be careful in that realm too
it's just i don't know man this is it's
a touchy one it's a touchy one yeah good
good and i'm really trying i'm really
trying no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no you're fine all right great great
points
i want to give it all to my boy boom you
know when this news came across to you
you know what's your feeling what's your
thoughts on this whole situation
well i mean at the overall picture it's
bad uh the you know uh
hustle had a a tremendous amount of
incredible points uh you know an artist
cannot be uh put into a box right we we
we as
content creators want to create our
content that represents us
this new
in imposing uh uh you know uh law
by a dictator uh led comp uh a country
is is bad for gaming there there is a
reason folks listen there is a reason
why and i don't want to turn this into a
a an acquisition conversation but it but
it's a part of it
um there is a reason why microsoft and
even sony are making these acquisitions
because they're starting to see this
this is i know i know that the the the
fun talk is this is acquisition season
no this is more like consolidation
season
because what's happening
is
you're gonna see
king's on to something
10 cent is big he's been talking about
this i've been talking about listen i
i'm not saying not to trust 10 cent i'm
saying that you there have their
hooks into a lot
of developers and there's a reason for
it and they are going to be told what to
do and how to do it by the chinese
government and if you can't get said
player kissing another said player then
you're and you're and you have some they
have 22 percent of your company you're
kind of going to be stuck
right so creators
yeah these developments these
development houses both small and big
are going to find themselves pushed up
against the wall
and they're going to have to do it the
way they
they don't want to do it and you're
going to see this is this is a this is a
growing problem that needs to be
addressed and you know something i'm not
a politics kind of a dude i i kind of
want to just love everybody but this is
one of those this is one of those uh
this goes to the exclusive not to the
inclusive yes
conversation and this is this is not
good uh i i i when i actually saw people
drop that into my dm about the 22 thing
i was like i did this
yeah
i had i had a devastated look at my
business because now yes it's it's it's
not controlling it's only 22 but it's
still 22
and we don't know what other companies
that they have that stake potentially
more
in right you know like kingdoms may have
made it funny here drop the bed go pay
your rent where and everyone's
everyone's excited and then you get the
little note on the device
well i can't do this but that's the
truth
that's the truth and that is why you're
going to see
microsoft and sony and several other of
these big publishers start consolidating
start
acquiring i'm not going to say that it's
going to come down to maybe three or
four entities owning everything that
that's probably not going to happen they
can't do that but embrace a group is a
perfect example of how it can happen yes
they have 76 developers folks
quietly
70s and you have over listen to this
they have over
300 ips embracer group a lot of people
didn't know that about that and then
what have they been doing quietly
getting seven here six here eight here
and no one pays embrace a group any any
mind because they see the big picture
they see the 10 cent situation happening
and they have
76
developers right folks this is why when
i start hearing oh microsoft is turning
into a monopoly i laughed like you
people don't know business
yeah real real this is this is this is
bad this is bad for the people this is
bad for gamers this is could potentially
turn into something very serious uh
china is you know they monitor
everything yeah there and they control
the narrative hell they cut they
i mean look look what happened with
several i mean look what happened with
shanxi
yeah did that get into china yes it did
not get into china
you know are the eternals getting into
china no
it is not they're they are controlling
the narrative it is bad for the world
that is bad specifically for gaming i i
will say i'll leave it at that i
remember and specifically with sean
cheese some some comments about
you know
the actor actresses not being beautiful
enough for the government yeah they
didn't according to the report they
didn't look
uh chinese enough for that which is
ridiculous i didn't hear that it was
surprising that whole thing it was the
art direction and and their choices
right
and again
how disney wants to make their movies
disney wants to make their movies right
right how disney marvel slash marvel
wants to make their movies that's up to
them yeah and if the that government
doesn't want and that's a large market
it's a large market yeah it's a huge
market for movies but um for for the
layman for the guys that's trying to
figure out why we so up in arms imagine
you get in that 52 box the crayola right
and they said okay here you go here's
your crayola guy comes over and says yo
here you go oh man thank you i needed to
finish off uh this painting uh and i
needed some um some i was doing some
abstract stuff with these crayons thank
you so much i didn't have the money to
purchase this but you purchased these
crayons for me all right cool um by the
way give me red black yellow
and orange and green turned into eight
yeah
have you have your fun with that i'll
take the red black orange and um green
and uh oh give me yellow all right have
fun yeah yeah that was real it's real
you're just sitting there with your face
like
dude how am i supposed to finish the the
artwork that i was trying to do right
with this limiting thing that you're
doing here like i'm an artist i need to
have all the crayons in my 52 box in
order to make that the great art
this is
like
censorship
of restrictions at its finest hustle was
on to something when he was talking
about it
and i'm
i'm just so
fearful
for what lies ahead going forward when
they find a different tactic in limiting
us remember they tried to stop us with
mortal kombat
remember that that was a big deal back
that was a huge thing huge deal
they tried to do it again with hot
coffee
every every couple of years it rears its
ugly head
and this in this time y'all never
thought that it will hit
over in this area because we love our
japanese anime games they have a
feminine men in a lot of these games all
right
and
i love the last of us too i wouldn't
have gotten certain scenes out of the
last of us too if um these viewpoints
were able to be held all right neil
druck we will not have the greatness of
neil druckmann being seen
if he has to uh beholden to these
companies in this manner
i'm fearful yeah
that they're finding a new tactic to
attack us
and they're doing it from the within
instead of through legislation
yeah let me let me pause you guys
everybody fantastic points um king
definitely proud of you bringing this
subject to my attention photo for the
realm definitely needed to be spoken i
want to also shout out i'll be remiss i
have to shout out um also the home team
with uh colin colin moriarty and uh last
stand media because they have been
beating this drum for the longest you
know and it's like why is no one else
talking about it and again you know cog
i try to stay out of politics as much as
i can i'm here for the fun in the game
but if it affects gaming i got to talk
about it right so at the end of the day
it's just like yes
cake said it best like
not every bag is a good bag you know not
every bag is a good you got to be
mindful and and and also hustle you said
some great points which is the reason
when gaming is so important to me
because this to me is artistry you know
this is these are our creators these are
we get some of the most beautiful
stories and things told even from other
regions in a way that's just so cool so
it's like to put i am not a fan of
putting any restriction on anything to
me it's like
let the crea if that is his vision
or her vision
let them create let it be let it be now
it's up to us to say you know what i for
that vision i'm not going to support
that but i'm about allowing the vision
to exist
let the let the vision ex they have the
right so when you take these bags
ten saying or whomever be cognizant of
what you signing up for like king said
that white paper might get slid
underneath your door and your cutscene
your move your cut your character
removed and to me this hits hard shout
out to my last damn media dudes who are
in here from from the team is that
for the live event y'all that i went to
for all and it was the greatest games of
all time my pick was mass effect 2.
that game would not exist under this
current structure correct
one of my greatest games of all time
in my opinion would not exist under the
current censorship model
and that's sad that's sad and it's
something to be
mindful of you know king said also last
of us right you know something to be
mine
boom you've been on fire too it's just
we got to pay attention we got to wake
up and it's more than just games their
tendrils are also in some aspects of
games media their tendrils are in a lot
of places so just be cognizant because
this is something that is attacking the
art form that i like you know what i'm
saying that i love you know i'm saying
like i don't want anything some of the
best story excuse me some of the best
stories you hear you know are from these
games and from these characters that are
developed in story lines and you know
again great great subject be mindful
that's not a world thankfully that i
existed and i don't want to exist in you
know so i'm just we got to support we
got to be cognizant of it but that's
what i got let's get these super chats
and get on out of here and i'm going to
start with the raiden blade two pound
superchat they don't release that type
of game there hashtag done i guess no
doubt no doubt parasite green with a 20
pound super chat guys i have been so
engaged by your convos today that you
managed to get this 80s baby to finally
pop his super chat cherry keep
just have a chinese edition or games
don't sell okay oh wait wait wait wait
so i was going to bring that up i was
going to say what are the what are the
chances that we do see two different
versions of the game like that's
interesting
i mean that's going to cost a lot of
bread first and foremost but i kind of i
can envision the world where we see game
a of us everywhere else and then game b
for them over there man you know i
i thought about that i thought about
that it's interesting to see what
happened before
her gate and also chat we should be
concerned with ten set buying up stakes
and game companies you could see it with
the nba in hollywood where they have to
bend the knee
so china really doesn't like people of
color not good
no you know you gotta see what's going
on man
raiden blade looks like i got skipped
there we go raiden blade two pound super
chat china has already cut the gaming
time to two hours program wow
i don't have confirmation but if that's
true it's pretty scary ready
two two pounds super chat again imagine
zenimax had been brought by tencent
interesting
you know again i don't want to turn it
into cog i don't want i don't want to
take this off the rails we got to get
out of here but
this is a this is the reason why
microsoft i and again folks i i know
that the everyone hates microsoft
acquisition talk is real that comes up
almost every week in conversation they
can't buy everybody this is wrong
there's a reason why this is happening
and i'm not saying that it's right it's
wrong it's indifferent what i'm saying
is that they are looking to
be a part of the conversation but more
so protect the industry that they are a
part of and how you do that and
because they're so
uh they have so much money to spend they
can in fact do it you are literally
saving developers from going out of
business when and a perfect example is
you look at ninja theory you look uh you
look at in exile these are components
there's so many of them that would may
not exist
no good without that good point no a
valid point i tell people all the time
like that i'm defining duke as well
parasite green again five pounds which
are iron lords in my eyes are the wu
tang of youtube uh individually have
your own opinions and deliver them in
different way
that's kind of that's what i like that
is
killer though your ghosts you girls
[Laughter]
raider blade 2000 chat time for 10 cent
to sell off percentage in these studios
and then let's see
what else we got yeah they're not doing
that
i don't think they're playing uh oh yeah
let me get the whole on the super chair
oh you gotta
all i got this week is a recommendation
for the dragon quest anime on
crunchyroll it's so dang good
but anyways have a good sunday fellas we
appreciate it
yeah that's that joint that's the new
game that came out for the playstation
yo you stupid
it is not shut up
shout out to playlistgamer.net
in the building gotta shout out the
whole team my boyfriend you already know
what it is wait wait dragon quest
wait that's the first rpga right that's
ea no no no no no no no no
you talking about you getting talked
about dragon's age
oh okay yeah yeah
okay yeah okay yeah no i'm just trying
to figure out you good you're good shout
out to drawing tj drawing is affiliate
saying you fulfill your sir 5 super chat
china is not helping the gaming industry
they are hurting if you guys are right
that's why xbox and sony are buying
that's what bulma's alluding to that's
what's
one of the reasons why
because you know amazon's choice trying
to put their foot in that water and with
the with the stadium
oh yeah yeah it was it was a bunch of
though
google saw game pass was like hey
jack did you imagine buys a large steak
or the whole take two could you imagine
what gta 6 would be like there are
rumors about this happens
yeah really ten cents sitting at that
table when uh you know the weed of the
field you know you still have anybody
buying anybody big daddy feel good like
yeah yeah yeah
i'll tell you this if that if that is a
rumor i'm i'm almost like a thousand
percent sure if that's not going to
happen because you all see what gta is
yeah ain't no way they're going to allow
that to happen
offender
the new gta
they'll be polished up cleaned up shined
up just fine
you yo put the crest up for gabenomics
my indian brother he joined the role
salute
from india gabe and alex in the building
good to see you brother raiden
boys song oh debate you weren't here now
that's a good question does aaron know
because aaron wanted me to sing it but
i'm like ain't no song
it's just an instrumental yeah yeah but
i think i i did some some song or
whatever when i first did the boy thing
oh yeah i think you did yeah you bet you
just dropped bars to it when we first
debuted i forgot yeah you did a free
stab
no doubt shout out to rayden blade he
said um people need to find out five
pounds super chat people need
realization that people of color never
appeared in games as major characters
only now fair enough fair enough
splendiferous five dollars super chat
love to lord solve and lord addict
boomstick one of my favorite shows i
look forward to every week i do what i
can to support the shows
shout out to artie x no doubt r d
shout out to sony avengers with nexus
and fabric okay oh man so look we got to
get up out of here i'm going to read
this poem i got to get boom and hustle
out of here because they have been
rocking very long with us so we going to
do this poll for the week
new ilp with the recent interview and
statements by jim ryan wanted to reach
hundreds of millions to enjoy
playstation games how do you anticipate
sony accomplishing this the choices are
eight
first-party playstation games day and
date in subscription services like ps
plus or ps now b
first party playstation games on pc
cloud and mobile or c i don't care but
y'all better keep that same energy when
i'm playing ps5 games on my toaster so
shout out to everybody in the corral
when it comes out
please hit that vote when it goes out
another banger of a show
half the salute first my brother lord
boomstick excel
double barrel gaming one of the one of
the most pure-hearted individuals in
this yosemite
um pleasure to meet him in person
hang out you know go to e3 together when
we still could do those things and yeah
the energy
you know he always provides community
and just the way he helps everybody
again i want to give you your roses
brother because i really don't think
people understand how many people
that i have heard from your platform for
the very first time and then bring them
on because i'm like yo
boom you know what i'm saying give this
person a phrase some people come up to
him hey man would i be on your podcast
boom's like yeah absolutely grab them up
and i don't think it gets celebrated
enough so salute to you and obviously
like the hardest working man in the
business one of the best performers in
the pistons
damn near five shows that we have
but he's killing it man always a smile
great energy and we talk all the time
proud to call your friend brother where
can the fine people find you what you
have going on sir
i mean listen it was super super easy
the dms are always open i talk to
everybody uh listen giving someone a
voice uh is something that i'm proud to
say that i do uh it's super important i
think that more people need to do it uh
just because you've never podcasted
before doesn't mean that you do not have
a voice that people want to hear
um i think again i i i've always been
inclusive i've never been a part of the
exclusive club that does not flow well
with me that sends a bad message and the
more people that i can bring up i think
that it's super important it's what
community means right it's about
supporting others
for no reason other than just to be a
good guy
it's something it's my it's the way my
father was i mean i closed out my show
with everything that my father taught us
and he said son treat others how you
want to be treated also it doesn't cost
anything to be nice i live by those
rules each and every day
and bringing new voices to the community
is important uh because
getting different points of views
is important yes you know and that's why
i mean you're sort of super chat that he
everyone has a different view of
something that's that's important nobody
wants to be considered a yes man so if
you're interested in my content
i used to do four shows thanks to the
you're not doing six shows no more i i'm
doing three uh mondays tuesdays and
fridays uh they're uh you know obviously
i'm not saying that the fourth show
isn't gonna come back in 22 because i
think it is but it's going to be
something different i'm working right
now on some different things behind the
scenes
if you're interested in the content if
you're interested in potentially
uh you know listening to what we have to
say week in and week out at mr boomstick
on
excel on twitter
double barrel gaming on youtube and if
you are a said person and you want to
check that box off i was on a podcast
hit me up in the dm and we can make it
happen
definitely always shows love again if it
wasn't like i said it's been helped us
get over the thousand thousand
subscribers at one point yeah he was
just like look [ __ ] i believe in an iop
you guys are one of my favorite podcasts
it's a pleasure to help and we always
grateful and thankful so also make sure
subscribe to double barrel gaming hustle
motivate put it in there let's get going
over the 9k come on y'all
over there if you're new here you never
heard of boom hit go there hit that link
hit that subscribe button let's get our
brother the 9k because again the more we
get the more he gets the better stuff we
can provide for the community and give
back to you guys so salute to that shout
out to one bad [ __ ] super chat
much love to everyone in today's final
good people on and off camera great show
friends that's real thank you
you already know and of course the dmv's
finest man with the greatest
name right now and twitter that gives
inspiration to the youth
that's right
by god i definitely try and you know cog
man once again i want to
like really thank you king and i know
saab and addict on here but thank you
all for that coaster i don't really know
if y'all know what that mean to me
because
i mean you know i'm about normal i'm
about just as regular as i can be from
dc man so it really do mean something it
really definitely does mean something
ladies and gentlemen i am on the road to
1000
subscribers i'm almost at 600. go ahead
hit that subscribe button
please
go ahead and find me every tuesday with
lord attic 5 p.m eastern standard time
on this channel yeah lowe's podcast
channel so we we're gonna have fun we
will make history um
january i got some future plans for the
channel but pretty much january top top
of the year um everything should kind of
have evened itself out in my personal
life i'm finna go there i'm trying to
have a really good time i got something
called save slot saturday which i will
be bringing back that'll you know we'll
do that i got um something else called
history with hustle um it's pretty much
game in retrospective one
such as these so i got all of that stuff
in the works and just you know just work
with me not against me and you know
we're gonna rock man
uh boom i'm gonna hit you up because oh
you can't leave that collection on the
program brother and we gotta yeah
collaboration is coming in a big way i i
love
i love the the old school going back
game preservation is not talked about
enough
yeah there's no media if you guys saw
what i haven't in storage i could have a
whole apartment and i i can't wait to
get my own man cave to put it out there
it's really careful
90 plus games physical games dreamcast
so yeah we're definitely going to hook
up but we definitely got to get you one
of the shows and help push your channel
to 1000 because folks
youtube is hard remember that
is hard man absolutely yeah please
please shut up
you can't be out here
i should have said difficult yeah
you know what you've been brother but
now like hustle it's good to see you
know your elevation brother and like i
said
i'm proud to support you and uh shout
out to addict man he really believed in
you and i was like all right you know i
just got to offer for stuff and
he's been on it with you and i'm glad to
help you and assist you with your
journey as well i i don't know how i can
repay that gentleman man i do not know
i'll find a way at some point i'm sure
friendship is more than enough keep
doing it yes sir
[Laughter]
no doubt dude don't take the bag
shout out to
give me some catfish
a little aki i can't shut up
that's getting clipped clearly you
already know where you kidding five
people find you sir
yes i find me eating some roti
jamaican gym right
where
[Laughter]
well you can catch me uh cleaning this
house from head to toe
um uh you can catch me fixing this
camera and this microphone
and you can also catch me uh doing the
next media room where you're gonna
actually get a chance to see one of my
large-screen 77-inch televisions um and
uh some some video games and stuff like
that i want y'all to see uh i'm setting
up a separate room for some stuff and um
green screen stuff i want to do some
green screen fun stuff uh some
visualizations for you guys to have you
know um some iphone yeah we're gonna set
up that that beautiful new mic that
we've the right yes
yeah okay so what he's talking about is
he's talking about this
[Music]
talking about this
legendary remember the iop always puts
back into pockets we nobody's out here
buying nobody's out here getting yachts
king ain't got a yacht
can i say one thing what's up brother
but i i do want to like emphasize the
importance of a more professional setup
now granted if you can't afford it and
that's not a shot at nobody if you
really can't afford it that's fine yeah
i i don't know how i caught it i was
talking to my dad i said let me start
doing the youtube things i'm gonna put
i'm gonna put some bread up i said i
don't know how i'm gonna do it i said
but people gonna know who i am i said i
don't know how he's gonna get done he
kind of looked at me and he laughed a
little bit and you know but he always
but he always believed in me because i'm
a firm believer in the law of attraction
now i put that stuff out there
i watch it come back tenfold each and
every time i'm glad that y'all
reinvesting in the sound and everything
yeah as y'all can see you know i put
that working yeah you know you you've
been broke you've been on it you've you
motivated us that we had to stop our
game
i gotta really respect dealer yes
i gotta really respect dealer cause
dylan
you doing that stuff with your
microphone from your cell phone and then
that papa you guys cut that out so i
really respect dealer cause dylan keep
it funky deal and never get keep get
dilla is one of the true real ones and
puts people on too we gotta give him his
flowers
i'm so happy that we get a chance to
uh convene and communicate with a lot
of real individuals real solid people
boom's a real realistic person thank you
sir hustle's a real solid person these
are real solid people so please go to
their channels go
over there and
like subscribe follow leave a comment on
their videos i mean all that stuff
matters
um go to
the
logicgaming.net
[Music]
gaming news site on the web bar none no
disrespect
just please don't do this
don't say no names
i don't
um but listen
we do really good stuff over there these
guys work really really hard um some of
the best stuff that you're gonna catch
on the web um legion of doom fridays at
9 00 pm this last friday
is about
sweet nuts
paws
horse you you deserve to pause for that
listen no no listen listen pause i'm
telling you it's about sweet nuts oh
lord and catching it in your mouth oh
man
wow you go if if you go you'll
understand what i'm talking about it's
not what you think yeah i hope that's
not what you think
i would hope that it's funny as hell and
i guarantee you if you're having a bad
day yes go watch the last episode
because you're definitely gonna bust a
gun please have a pail next to your
[Music]
now
rebranded to legion of doom
go check it out you're going to die
laughing now the news is funny
good dudes good dudes hilarious got a
chance to meet them you know i'm saying
very welcoming got my first joint you
know what i'm saying certainly yeah a
lot of love on that you know somebody's
trying to get him to get that r yeah i
don't know i know what's trying to do
shout out to raiden blade two pounds of
[ __ ] guyanese roti with the curry duck
all right all right i'll see you i see
you do that right right now look we're
gonna get up out of here but um look
y'all again realm tremendous thank y'all
for pulling up boom always a pleasure
glad to do this with you man it's been
too long obviously yeah bring it back
again hustle the fam you already know us
please send some love
solve an attic yes reach out to yourself
again
so i'm going to leave y'all with the
sinister plug again
okay one more before you go okay
oh yeah please please okay okay go get
yeah yeah uh i just got in late um
don't know
boom oh i guess oh excuse me didn't know
what was on iop this week um salute to
you fine gentlemen i'm starting from the
beginning yeah okay this is a classic
bro this is
again one more shout out to my brother
sin if anything you guys could do i'll
get the links in the description for the
go fund me that's the best way yeah you
know you can help out the family again
he lost his his mom his dad and grandma
in the same year so please please send
your love i'm gonna leave you guys with
that yeah and on that peace and
blessings enjoy your sunday peace
hey guys lord cognito here with uh some
unfortunate news i definitely uh want to
speak to you everyone in the realm and
um as you know ilp we're pretty big and
we've got a lot of klan members and
associates and friends and this one goes
out to one particular friend in
particular from uh growing up from back
in the day since our channel five days
lord sinister
many of you may be familiar with him
he's always playing destiny with us in
the ilp clan
if you played uh or you've been in xbox
live party chats with me and anybody
from the the ilp fam you know the
sinister name he's always at the chats
always having fun and um probably helped
you in a raid or two
but uh unfortunately we're sad to
announce that you know his mother
um recently passed away this morning and
uh we definitely want to send loves and
thoughts and condolences to his family
to him as you know his beautiful wife
and son and children and then
obviously his mom which we lost he lost
suddenly and this year has been a rough
year for him it's particularly because
uh in april he lost his dad to covet
complications and his grandmother as
well so um
if anything the rum could do you know
when a fallen lord has fallen down and
going through a tough time you know we
want to reach out and we want to help as
best as we can so i'm putting this out
there call of arm to the realms just
help our brother lord sinister aka ergo
ortiz
good friend i've known this kid you know
since uh back in the south bronx just
playing games good guy and uh going
through some tough times so whatever we
can do to help would be greatly
appreciated and to really send off his
family the right way so it's lord
cognito here again any help is
appreciated and thank you for your time